Musik
MonkaW
windows ja franz ist ja ganz schön früh am start heute
so ein leute
weil ich hatte diese woche moment ich muss noch mal eine pil nehmen sehe ich gerade die kunde
So, jetzt.
Also, ich hatte heute...
Ey, heute, Blödsinn oder Schwachsinn, ey.
Ich sollte nicht zwei Sachen gleichzeitig machen.
Ich hatte die Woche
zwei Tage...
Schulung,
könnte man es so nennen.
Es war eher... Wobei, naja, Schulung
war es nicht wirklich. Das war so eine...
So eine Art Teambuilding.
Workshop zwei Tage.
Und das war echt anstrengend.
Man musste laufend irgendwas machen.
Ihr mögt sowas bestimmt auch, oder?
Ihr denkt euch dann auch immer, oh geil, endlich mal wieder ein Team-Building-Workshop.
Monka S.
Insgesamt ging es aber klar.
Ja, ne, wirklich Bock hatte ich auch nicht drauf.
Aber es ging schon klar irgendwo.
Zum Glück sind wir vor allzu vielen Spielchen verschont geblieben.
Also wir mussten nicht irgendwelche Netze aufbauen, Zelte aufbauen oder irgendwelche anderen komischen Spielchen machen.
Hielt sich stark in Grenzen.
Naja, also die Trainer haben da glaube ich Bock drauf, weil die verdienen damit Geld.
Es muss ja eh irgendwo in Deutschland, oder was in Deutschland, es muss ja eh auch Trainer geben, die die Trainer trainieren.
Was anders kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen, weil es kann sich doch nicht jeder Trainer selbst diese ganzen komischen Spiele da im Haus denken.
Moin.
Da muss es doch irgendein Trainertraining geben.
Für solche Workshops, oder?
Also, anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
die müssen sie müssen sich doch auch darüber austauschen was wir die neuesten
blöden spiele sind und so was so leute ich war mal kurz hier os updates
der ex ist auch unter linux unterwegs habe ich gehört immer noch oder nicht
mehr
Ein Kommunikationsworkshop.
Oh ja, viel
Spaß.
Das klingt ganz danach, als muss man
da bei vielen Sachen mitmachen.
Es ist keine Frontbeschallung, sondern
da muss man was
machen, weil sonst bringt es ja nichts.
Aber ja, solche Workshops sind
Was sind denn die Ziele bei einem Kommunikationsworkshop?
Fangen die da auch wieder mit so einem Esoterik-Kram an?
Wie, äh, welche Farbe bist du und so komisches Zeug?
Ah.
Ja, Sound oder Linux ist absolut Fans-Champ.
übrigens
das ist auch das sender empfänger modell ja das kenne ich auch dass das hat uns auch mal
irgendeiner von den Tränen erzählt.
Letztendlich muss man aber mal sagen,
also unabhängig von diesem ganzen Zeug,
was in diesen Workshops gelabert wird,
so Kommunikation
an sich, also
ich sag euch was und ihr versteht das und so,
ist eigentlich schon beeindruckend,
wie gut das in der Regel
funktioniert. Es wird ja da immer drauf rumgeritten,
was die Probleme sind oder so, aber
im Großen und Ganzen muss man echt mal sagen,
funktioniert das erstaunlich gut. Da muss ich das
mal überlegen. Also, wenn ich mir
jetzt irgendwas denke im Kopf, ja,
dann ist das bei mir
im Kopf als Gedanken. So.
Dann muss ich das sagen,
dann wird das Ganze in Schallwellen
umgewandelt,
dann geht das in eure
Ohren rein und im besten Fall
habt ihr danach das gleiche im Kopf,
was ich vorher gedacht hab.
So. Dass das nicht immer 100%
funktionieren kann,
ist klar, aber es funktioniert
erstaunlich gut.
Also für das, was da alles schief gehen kann, funktioniert miteinander reden erstaunlich gut.
Ja, offene Fehlerkultur finde ich auch immer geil, wenn sie das sagen, so nach dem Motto,
ah hier, wir blamen keinen für irgendwelche Fehler und offene Fehlerkultur, kaum geht irgendwas kaputt und wer war's?
Zumindest war das in meiner alten Firma so, in der neuen nicht, aber in der alten.
Das sind so Dinge, also
Ja, solange nichts wirklich passiert
Kann man immer sagen, offene Fehlerkultur
Aber wenn dann mal was passiert, ist das meistens ganz schnell wieder vorbei
So, ich mach mal kurz die Updates fertig
Richutils, brauch ich das überhaupt noch?
Ich nehm mal
Du hast ein Selfmade Game
Du hast einen eigenen Stuhl gebaut
Was hast du als Basis genommen?
Ikea Markus oder?
Oder wirklich komplett selbst gebaut?
So, Leute.
Was wir jetzt machen ist,
also mein Nass ist ja da.
Das müssen wir uns auch angucken.
Aber vorher würde ich gerne noch was anderes ausprobieren.
Und zwar, ich habe ja hier noch so ein Mini-PC rumstehen.
So ein hier.
der ist gar nicht schlecht von der Hardware.
Der hat, ne, die 32 Gig hat er nicht, die 32 Gig, die habe ich immer nass eingebaut und habe jetzt 8 Gig hier drin.
Zumindest, das hat 8 Core, 16 Threads, 5 Core, also das ist ein Ryzen, das Ding ist gar nicht schlecht.
Was ich ja ausprobieren wollte ist, ich installiere Linux drauf.
Vielleicht schaffen wir es nämlich, meine VM hier, die da, abzulösen mit einer echten Hardware-Linux-Kiste
und können dann auch mal uns ein bisschen über Wayland wieder aufregen.
Ah ja, nice.
Ach, ah, du hast einen Autositz genommen.
Da können wir vielleicht hier mal eine Linux-VM durch die Kiste ablösen.
wird natürlich wieder richtig
Paintschamp werden, ich kann euch das jetzt schon
prophezeien, weil unter Wayland
wird wahrscheinlich Keyboard-Mouse-Sharing nicht
richtig funktionieren, wahrscheinlich
Clipboard-Sharing nicht richtig funktionieren, sonstige
Dinger nicht richtig funktionieren
aber wir probieren das
trotzdem mal aus, bisschen schwierig
wird es natürlich, weil ich muss das ja dann
hier ins OBS einbinden, das heißt ich muss
das Ganze dann eh über eine Capture-Card laufen
lassen, beziehungsweise halt mit einem durchgeschleiften
Monitor, dass ich das hier auf dem zweiten Bildschirm
sie weil das gelege von der capture card gebe ich mir nicht und dann kann ich
wenn ich auf linux bin keine kubz keine e-mails mehr einblenden ja und ich muss
und ich muss szenen switchen anstatt einfach nur desktop switchen also das
könnte das könnte etwas abfuck werden
Sind wir eine ERK-Abschlussprüfung jetzt?
Jetzt wird es aber richtig advanced hier.
Und hat dein Stuhl wenigstens auch LED, RGB?
Für mehr FPS.
So, Updates haben wir schon gemacht.
Reboot.
Ich bin mit einem Kollegen zusammen zur Schulung gefahren und er hat ein Auto mit Lenkradheizung
und die Lenkradheizung geht nur, wenn er ein Abo abschließt, wo wir gerade bei Abo sind.
Ist auch geil, oder?
Ist drinnen, wird über das Display gesteuert, kein Ding, aber du brauchst ein Abo dafür.
man sich mal vorstellen kaufst ein auto mit lenkradheizung aber das geht nur wenn du pay
world paywall lenkradheizung auch geile ist ja bei meinem ähnlich bei mir ist ja so den akku
stein meines elektroauto den akkustand in der app anzeigen würde man jetzt eigentlich von ausgehen
ist eines der most basic features überhaupt von dem elektroauto dass man in der app gucken kann
er sagt mal wie ist eigentlich der akku stand ja oder weil sie wieder sehen aber ich würde
sagen dass er so ziemlich basic functionality dass das ein akkustand in der app anzeigt es
geht aber auch nicht ich brauche ein basic wie auch immer es heißt abo für mein fiat dass das
den Akkuladestand in der App anzeigen lassen kann.
Und im Home Assistant geht die Akkustandanzeige auch kaputt.
Nach einer Zeit, wenn das Abo abgelaufen ist.
Also man muss wirklich ein Abo abschließen von Fiat.
Und ganz ehrlich, Leute.
Bei Fiat, weiß ich hier, warte mal.
Keine Ahnung, ob ich das jetzt finde.
Ja
Also wer sich diese Seite
Bei Fiat ausgedacht hat
Alter, diese Seite ist so
Dermaßen schlecht, Alter
Mit dem Shop
Du findest das jetzt gar nicht
Die ist so dermaßen kacke, Alter
Wer sich diese Seite ausgedacht hat
Mit diesem Shop
Okay, jetzt funzt
Irgendwie nicht richtig, was auch immer
Also ganz ehrlich
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was die da gemacht haben
es wurden erst nicht die richtigen Pakete angezeigt,
dann habe ich ein Paket gekauft,
dann ist das andere verschwunden,
was ich eigentlich auch, also ganz
wir, also ganz ehrlich, die
Software, also Online-Services bei
Fiat kannst du komplett knicken.
Also vom
Auto her würde ich sagen, was
mir persönlich am meisten zusagen würde,
so von diesen ganzen
Smart-Features und sowas, ist
tatsächlich Tesla. Was ich da bisher
gelesen habe, ist, dass du da noch am meisten auch modden
und machen und tun und machen und
dingsen kannst.
Kannst ja mittlerweile wohl
in deinem Auto sogar Steam installieren.
Ja, rebooted.
So, das sehen wir mal wieder.
Chat,
wenn ich dann
Helenos drauf
installiere, ne, was braucht man
für eine Distribution nehmen. Ich habe gedacht,
wir machen schon...
Klar läuft das locker.
Bei Tesla sind irgendwelche Ryzen...
Irgendwas auf Ryzen-Basis
glaube ich drin in den Autos.
Ich würde ja sagen, wir gehen
da mit dem Hype CacheOS.
Wir könnten aber auch auf...
Ja, kommen wir installieren CacheOS auf der Kiste
und gucken mal, wie gut
oder schlecht das funzt auf echter Hardware.
Und dann, was ich mal die ganze
Zeit schon ausprobieren wollte...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das machen wir nicht. Das machen wir nicht.
Das kann ich jetzt schon sagen. Das wollen wir garantiert nicht.
Ähm, ne, Omachi
hab ich keinen Bock drauf. Da verstehe ich die
Begeisterung davon nicht.
Äh, jetzt hab ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte.
Ey, ne, wir machen Cachy. Wir machen CachyOS
drauf. Ach ja, soll ich euch mal
was Cooles zeigen?
Das muss ich ja auch euch im Stream mal zeigen,
ich das gemacht habe vorher irgendwas wollte ich gerade noch sagen wir waren cash us drauf
da guck mal wie das funzt ob ich dann benutzen werde weiß ich nicht müssen wir mal schauen
zumindest habe ich ganz gute chancen weil es eine amd basierte kiste ist mit reisen und amd gpu und
sowas. Das heißt, im Endeffekt sollte das unter Linux
eigentlich ganz gut funktionieren.
Ja.
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Das probieren wir mal aus. Und regen uns garantiert
wieder über Wayland auf. Das weiß ich jetzt schon.
Das wird auf jeden Fall so kommen.
Irgendwas wird da...
Irgendwelche Basic-Sachen werden nicht
funktionieren. So, keine Ahnung.
Mauszeiger haben das falsche
icon clipboard geht nicht copy paste ist kaputt irgendwas irgendwas wird auf
jeden fall richtig abfangen über eltern das weiß ich jetzt schon auch auf auch
auf native hardware ich zeige euch mal was cooles guck mal
hier leute ich habe ein pxe setup jetzt wirklich advanced also das was wir
letztens im stream gemacht haben habe ich am pxe server aufgesetzt mit
verschiedenen linux distributionen drin und meine mein spezial db an cloud
image zum installieren ich habe das jetzt noch ein bisschen erweitert guck mal hier wir legen
jetzt mal der vm an jetzt wir installieren jetzt allerdings drauf zeigt euch nur mal liegen jetzt
der vm man hier zack ich installiere later linux ja bla blub hier was ich das eigentlich vollkommen
egal was man da auswählen weil wir installieren wie gesagt installieren nix bridge networking
logic 20 24 32 vielleicht in ziel immer doch was zum zeigen sagt sagt
tronkarte kann man raus machen die mache ich immer raus display accelerate falls
wir noch was installieren klaus so jetzt passt mal auf wie nice das ist das ist
Extremely Pog.
Oder ihr müsst mir sagen, ob das Extremely Pog ist.
Also ich finde das enorm
Pog. Guckt mal hier.
Wird das gestartet? Oh ne, Moment,
Moment, Moment.
Alter.
Guckt mal hier.
Pass mal auf. PXE-Booting.
So, erstmal.
Ist das nicht ein tolles
PXE-Boot-Menü?
Ich weiß es ist ein KI Bild, okay?
Aber es sieht trotzdem gut aus.
Ist das nicht ein nices PXE Menü mit Image Support, Leute?
PXE Boot
1024x768 mit Image Support.
So, man kann sich sogar die Netzwerk-Config anzeigen lassen von PXE Boot. Oh, okay, was jetzt? Was jetzt?
Ah hier
Das backt, backt gerade ein bisschen rum
Vor allem wer
Hat sie, ja
Man kann sich hier sogar
Alter, vor allem wer
Please, Sekunde
Vor allem wer spackt wieder richtig krass rum
Vor allem, weil er ist wieder richtig am Abspacken gerade.
War richtig heftig, ja.
So, hier sind wir jetzt.
Net-Config.
Ey, was backt das denn so rum?
Was backt das hier so rum?
Guck mal mal, das Natur geht nicht richtig.
Das ist jetzt nur in der VM auf diesem Account.
Danke Broadcom, ja.
Guck mal, was ich mittlerweile alles drin habe.
Man kann lokal booten.
Dann passiert natürlich nichts.
Dann, ne?
Weil, was soll passieren?
Dann startet er wieder über PXE.
Alter, wie das kaputt ist.
Heckel, Alter.
Naja.
So, man kann, also man kann Netboot XYZ starten, man kann Clonezilla starten.
Man kann eine System Rescue CD starten, eine System Rescue CD mit ZFS Support drin.
Man kann den aktuellen Linux Mint.
Live-CD starten, man kann den Cache-OS-Installer starten und man kann den Debian-Installer starten,
beziehungsweise einen Debian-Installer mit Pre-Seed oder man kann mal ein spezielles Cloud-Image verwenden zum Installieren.
Das ist eh das Beste für schnelle Install-Geschichten.
Wer das nicht gesehen hat, ich zeige das mal kurz, das ist eh mega nice.
Also wenn ich jetzt eine neue VM brauche, ich zeige euch mal, wie einfach das geht.
hier nicht erst drei Stunden Installer durchklicken
oder sonst was. So, zack, so ein neuer
VM angelegt. Einfach warten, bis
PXE-Boot gestartet ist.
Auch das, der Bildschirm hier schwarz
ist nicht normal, ne?
Vmware macht wieder irgendwelchen
Bullshit. Guckt euch das an.
Was ist denn da wieder?
Guck mal hier! Was ist denn da wieder
kaputt, alter Vmware? Was ist das hier?
Keck Wait
ist das.
Warum ist der Bildschirm hier jetzt schwarz?
Normalerweise sieht man hier PXE-Booten.
Ganz, ganz furchtbar weird, was VMware da wieder treibt.
So, zumindest wenn man jetzt ein neues Debian installieren will.
Debian Cloud Image geht man einfach auf Install.
Alter, VMware, please, VMware.
Das ist kaputt.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Dann starten wir jetzt einfach Cache.
Geht das vielleicht wenigstens bei gerade...
Okay, das scheint zu funktionieren.
Moin, Umut.
So, jetzt lädt er sich das aktuelle Cache-OS runter.
Beim letzten Mal hat er auch schon alles doppelt ausgeführt.
Ja, ist ganz furchtbar weird, was das Ding da treibt, ey.
Weird Champ ist das.
Guck, jetzt lädt er sich das aktuelle Cache-US von meinem lokalen Server runter und startet
gleich alles.
In der Hoffnung, dass er immer mitspielt.
Hoffen wir mal.
So, und dann habe ich noch ein bisschen was gekryptet.
Glasfaser am Start.
Ne, das ist lokal von meinem Server.
Ich hab das alles lokal liegen.
Deswegen hat das 110 MB.
Ne, ne, ich lad mir das nicht aus dem Internet.
So, kann man jetzt hier starten.
Und was ich mir gebaut hab ist,
während CacheOS jetzt hier bootet,
das bootet immer ziemlich langsam.
Und irgendwann startet's dann auch.
So, und da ist es.
So, aber, was ich euch noch zeigen wollte,
können wir mal da lassen,
so ein PXE-Boot-Test-Ding kann man immer gebrauchen.
Wie namen wir das mal?
PXE-Boot.
So, was ich mir geskriptet habe,
ist folgendes.
Hattest du nicht lokal 10 Gig?
Ja, hatte ich.
Habe ich auch immer noch.
Aber, wenn ich mich auf die Kiste verbinde,
werdet ihr sehen,
Das ist ein Raspberry Pi.
Das ist ein Raspberry Pi, deswegen der hat nur einen Gig.
Warum genau habe ich hier eigentlich Docker installiert?
Das brauche ich hier gar nicht drauf.
Upt, purge, Docker.
Oder brauche ich das doch?
Docker ist not installed.
Moment!
Wenn Docker not installed ist,
Warum habe ich hier einen Docker Interface
Vielleicht hatte ich Docker mal installiert
Und der hat den Kram nicht gelöscht, kann das sein
Ja, das ist ja Mist
Jetzt habe ich so ein random Docker Interface
Weil ich nicht brauche
Zumindest
War www.html
Hacked
Ja, das wird es sein
Guck mal, ich habe hier ein Skript gebaut
Update
ja hier liegt das ganze Demian Zeug, keine Ahnung
ich hab ein Skript gebaut, was mir
wöchentlich
die neuesten
ähm
ich nenn's mal ISOs zieht
ja, das
zieht mein Demian Cloud Image
neueste Netboot, neueste Clonezilla
neueste System Rescue CD
neueste Linux Mint, Demian Installer
und neueste CacheOS
und das ist wirklich advanced geskriptet
weil, der guckt nach
Also das ist nicht einfach hardcoded, dass der das Neueste zieht.
Der guckt hier nach, was ist die Neueste.
Also der holt sich hier raus beispielsweise, was ist die letzte CacheOS ISO und dann lädt er die runter.
Also das ist immer aktuell, sofern die ihre Webseite nicht ändern.
Das ist immer aktuell.
Oder auch hier beim Debian Installer.
Der guckt nach auf dem Debian FTP, was im letzten Stable Release File drin steht, holt sich dann den Codename raus und kann dann hier das Neueste downloaden.
Oder bei Mint ist auch so.
Der guckt hier bei der End of Life API nach, was das letzte Stable Linux Mint ist, holt sich den Release Name raus, lädt dann die XFCE ISO runter.
Genauso hier bei System Rescue CD.
wobei es sind also es sind keine isos in dem sinn weil px von iso geht nicht richtig du musst dann
immer die könnte immer den kölner drin auspacken guckt das macht er hier beispielsweise auch der
holt sich nehmen wir mal hier cash us ja cash us leder sich die iso runter dann entpackt er
aus der ISO, also der pipet
quasi den Output von Weget.
Kein Check,
ob du die Version schon hast. Woher soll ich denn wissen, dass ich die Version
schon habe?
Beispielsweise bei Debian heißt der Kram
ja immer gleich.
Ich lösche das und dann wird es neu runtergeladen.
Da weißt du, dass es auch immer das Aktuelle ist.
So, der pipet,
der downloadet das, pipet
nach BSD, der
der entpackt aus dem ISO dann wirklich nur die Files, die man braucht.
Ja, hier BakeshiOS, beispielsweise Dienungskernel, InitramFS und das Root-Filesystem.
Und legt das dann hier ab.
Und hier ist das ganze Zeug dann drin.
Ja, wenn man jetzt hier beispielsweise bei Mint guckt oder bei, guck mal, Bakeshi.
Ja, Bakeshi legt dann im Endeffekt nur,
liegt da nur dieses Zeug hier drin rum, ja?
Nur diese drei Dateien, nicht die ganze ISO oder sowas.
So, jetzt muss ich aber doch nochmal gucken,
ich weiß, auch wenn es super krass sidetracked ist,
warum mein Debian-Installer-Image-Boot nicht richtig funktioniert.
Also das liegt, ohne Scheiß, das liegt an VMware.
Normalerweise sieht man immer hier, was der macht.
Das ist total kaputt.
Ich weiß nicht, was Broadcom getrieben hat.
ich glaube ich downgrade wieder auf vmware 18
weil es ist komplett
guck mal, seht ihr das jetzt
es hing sogar beim ausschalten
weil es ist komplett kaputt
wisst ihr was wir machen, wir machen mal hier die
accelerate
3d graphics raus, vielleicht
bringt das mehr, keine ahnung
ach da
ach wenn man accelerate 3d graphics
raus macht, dann geht es oder was
So, warum ist mein Debian-Installer kaputt?
Was?
Image not found.
Wie Image not found?
Was ist da kaputt?
Warum geht mein Debian-Installer nicht?
Sekunde.
Boot.ipxe.
Debian.
Hier.
Warum geht das nicht?
Warum ist hier was nicht?
Found.
Installer.
Hier.
Install-Image.
Init-RD.
VM.
Ah
Ich glaube, ich weiß warum
Mein Skript ist kaputt
Der packt nur
Die Debian Images hier
So, aber
Okay, das gucke ich mir jetzt nicht im Stream mit euch an
Aber, okay, das macht natürlich Sinn
Das habe ich irgendwie
Destroyed
Warum?
Was habe ich da kaputt gemacht?
Bistro?
Using?
Hier packe ich die Images
Ich packe hier überhaupt nichts aus.
Ich dab.
Okay.
Whatever.
So, dann machen wir mal...
Ne, wobei, Systemupdates
habe ich schon gemacht.
Habe ich vorhin schon gemacht.
Wir haben auch schon rebooted.
Dann lasst uns auch mal kurz gucken.
Was auf GitHub so trennet.
Ach übrigens.
Ich habe wieder richtig Pepo Burn Money gemacht.
Letztens.
Und zwar.
Ich habe mir doch ein neues NAS bestellt.
Weil ich mir gedacht habe.
Es wird mal Zeit.
Für was Neues.
Mein HP Microserver.
funktioniert noch wunderbar,
aber mir ist danach,
was Neues hinzustellen.
Dann habe ich mir das Ding hier bestellt.
Dieses Teil habe ich mir bestellt.
Das steht auch hier, Leute,
steht neben mir gerade.
Das ist schon da.
Was ich nicht gemacht habe, ist,
ich habe mir nicht die Sache mit RAM gekauft
und sowas, sondern ich habe
die 32 GB RAM,
diese kleinen RAM-Bausteine,
wie heißt das, S0 oder so,
habe ich noch 32 Gig gehabt, die habe ich eingebaut.
Weil ganz ehrlich, mit den aktuellen RAM-Preisen
hätte ich mir das nicht gekauft. Aber
und jetzt kommt der Punkt, wo ich
Paper Burn Money gemacht habe.
Nachdem ich das
gekauft habe, nachdem das angekommen ist,
haben die ein neues NAS
vorgestellt.
Nämlich das hier.
Das ist
einfach genau das gleiche.
Außer dass die Farbe ein bisschen anders aussieht.
Das ist einfach genau das gleiche.
Nur, dass die CPU besser ist.
Und einen Performance-Score mehr hat.
Und es kostet nur ein paar Euro hier Unterschiede.
40, 50 Euro Unterschied.
Dann habe ich mir das hier auch noch bestellt.
So.
Und.
Jetzt habe ich zwei nass.
Die ich nicht brauche.
Also ich brauche nicht zwei.
Einfach mal 600 Euro in Sand gesetzt
Was heißt in Sand gesetzt?
Hast du das schon angemacht?
Ja
So, aber das hier ist ja noch nicht da
Warum das alte nicht zurückgeschickt?
Naja, ich habe schon ein bisschen dran rumgebaut
Aber ganz davon abgesehen
Ich habe mir überlegt
Die Lautstärke ist relativ leise
Ich habe mir überlegt, was man machen könnte
Wenn wir uns das im Stream
Also wenn ich das hier wirklich nicht brauche, wenn ich dafür keinen Verwendungszweck finde,
dann werde ich das einfach give away im Stream.
Aber Leute, ohne SSDs und ohne RAM.
Das heißt, RAM behalte ich.
So viel kann ich euch schon mal sagen.
RAM gibt es nicht umsonst.
Ne, die Lautstärke ist nicht laut.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das ist nicht laut.
Also ich hab das hier direkt, hier,
ich weiß nicht, ob man es hört, ja, direkt neben mir stehen.
Ähm, zum
Basteln gehabt. Und
das hat ein bisschen, das hat leise
gerauscht. Also, das ist jetzt nix,
was ich mir auf den Tisch stellen würde.
Neben dem Monitor,
ja. Aber wenn das
ein bisschen weiter weg steht, oder gerade
wenn das da hinten bei mir im Serverraum drin steht,
also, du wirst davon gar nix hören.
Mit RAM,
da sind 32 GB RAM drin,
hier in meinem NAS jetzt.
Ähm, 32 Gigramm, was kosten, was kosten mittlerweile 32 Gigramm S0 dem, Moment, das muss ich jetzt gerade mal gucken.
Sekunde, erstmal was trinken.
So, ähm...
Arbeitsspeicher.
Ähm...
SO-DIMM oder S0?
Was heißt denn?
Ist das eine 0 oder eine O?
SO ist das, oder?
Wofür steht das SO
bei SO-DIMM?
Denkprozess.
Small Outline.
Aha.
So, und jetzt DDR5.
So.
32 Gig.
Oh, oh, oh.
Äh, 32 Gig.
Ich such das Preis pro Gig.
Das günstigste Preis pro Gig.
32, 32.
Gibt's da nicht 32?
Ich dachte 32 ist so ein Standardding.
Hier, 32.
Ja.
Das geht doch eigentlich noch.
Klar, oder?
Ich dachte, es wäre teurer mittlerweile.
Hä, warum ist denn das wieder billiger geworden, Leute?
Leute, warum sind die Rampreise wieder so gefallen?
Was ist da los?
Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Was ist denn da los?
Was ist denn das?
Das ist doch Chebat.
Ist das G-Bait?
Warte mal, will ich überhaupt so einen komischen RAM hier?
Ich such mal hier nach 32.
32 Gig.
Datenmenge pro Kit.
Hier 32.
Crucial 32 Gig.
Geht doch.
480.
Letztendlich ist mir das vollkommen egal.
Boah, das schwankt aber.
Alter, das schwankt aber. Was ist denn da los?
Warum schwankt das so heftig?
Warum schwankt das so krass gerade?
Ich meine, es ist natürlich...
Okay, es ist natürlich immer noch ein heftiger Unterschied.
Guckt mal.
Es hat vor einem Jahr...
Ne, Moment mal, Moment mal.
Es hat letztes Jahr im August vor einem halben Jahr
hat es noch 78 Euro gekostet.
Und jetzt schwankt das...
Ich meine, es ist immer noch schweineteuer, ne?
Das ist immer noch...
Von wegen, das geht schon.
Ich hab mir das im Kopf so überlegt.
Oh ja, das geht schon 200.
Das ist immer noch schweineteuer.
Teuer as fuck.
Gibt es mittlerweile schon irgendwelche Seiten,
wo man RAM-Preise
refresht und RAM-Module
snipen kann?
So nach dem Motto,
sobald es unter...
Gab's doch für Grafikkarten mal.
So nach dem Motto, sobald der RAM-Preis unter 200 Euro fällt, BÄM, kaufen.
BÄM.
RAM-Sniper.
Gibt es sowas?
Ra-Ra-RAM-Sniper?
Äh, nein.
Memory.
Ach, die heißen Sniper.
Ja gut, da hätte ich damit rechnen können.
Dass es RAM gibt.
Super Fatality Headshot Killer Pro.
Der Preis-Champ für RAM.
Es wird eigentlich mal wieder Zeit, Leute.
Moment.
Chat, Chat.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was ist das für eine Domain, Alter?
Gehört mir die Domain überhaupt noch?
Alter, war es preischeng.org oder .com?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Ich glaube .org, ne?
Ähm, Chat, ich zeige euch nochmal was Nices, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich hab, ich hab, ähm...
die letzte woche was progat und zwar guck mal hier repos der go domain champ
ist am start so hier ist das bild und der go domain champ der kann so was hier
machen guck mal app list minus minus domains gleich und jetzt immer hier
preis champ punkt org rein
dann zeigte einem nämlich an wann der expired wurde registriert ist und was
dafür ein dns hat ist das nicht mal ist man kann übrigens auch mehr man kann da übrigens noch mehr
mit reinpacken ja also wir können auch wo bloß punkt tv max fps punkt tv google.com max fps punkt
de und sowas mit reinpacken und dann malte eine nice tabelle mit den ganzen expire dates und wenn
es kleiner 60 tage ist glaube ich oder kleiner 30 dann wird es auch gelb und irgendwann rot ja da
sieht man wo das registriert ist und der dns hier die deutschen domains sind natürlich wieder
besonders besonders privacy mäßig unterwegs die geben keine informationen zu exploration und
registrar raus aber am dns erkennt man auch dass diese domain immer noch bei nitrado liegt alter
so und das kann auch mehr guck mal hier weil es nämlich help eingibt aber nämlich noch mehr
machen man kann einstellen ab wann die warning farben kommen und man kann die
zeiten auch noch ein bisschen besser umstellen ja also man kann zum beispiel
auch sagen ich will hier time als rfc passbar anzeigen guckt da kriegt man hier
den timestamp so oder ja und wisst ihr was auch nice ist was auch nice ist
source
App.
Completion.
ZSH.
Ach, man muss da Domains angeben.
Okay, Max, das ist ziemlich doof von dir.
Dass man auch Domains für Completion angeben muss.
Das ist ein Bug.
Mach ich das übrigens gerade richtig überhaupt?
Ach, minus CZSH muss ich machen.
Okay.
Ja, das ist noch nicht so ganz ausgereift.
Hä?
Ach, weil ich habe wieder Domains.
Okay, das ist ziemlich dumm.
Jetzt geht es.
So, weil guckt, jetzt hat man sogar hier...
Hat man nicht.
Ach, weil das Ding Domain Champ heißt.
Aha.
Das muss Domain Champ heißen.
Okay.
Äh.
Okay, ich hab nix gesagt.
Irgendwie punzt das mit...
...punzt das mit der Shell Completion nicht richtig.
Ach, jetzt muss...
Okay, das ist...
...das ist natürlich Paints Champ, Alter.
Das ist ziemlich im Arsch, was ich da gebaut habe.
Jetzt funzt.
Okay, das ist natürlich nicht so...
Das ist natürlich nicht so clever, ja?
Das ist natürlich nicht so clever.
Also, im Prinzip funktioniert aber die Autocompletion, ja?
Ja.
So, und was man auch noch machen kann, ist...
Man kann auch sagen, hier...
Reverse.
Dann kriegt man die Neuesten oben.
oder aber minus minus jason dann bringt er die sachen als von irgendwelchen
plank oder sowas passbare da printet er keine tabelle sondern hier passbar als
jason so und als bonus was auch noch nice ist man kann auch sagen so dann
printet er die ganzen Sachen hier auf der Konsole.
Aber, wenn ich
jetzt sage curl
localhost port 8080
slash
metrics, dann kriege ich das Ganze
als Prometheus-Metriken für die Domains
noch raus.
Das ist nice, oder?
Kann ich jetzt mit meinem Monitoring,
jetzt kann ich entweder in irgendeinem Log-Verwertungs-Ding
reinpacken oder aber
in mein Prometheus-Monitoring,
wann meine Domains expiren.
By the way.
By the way, Max.
Du hast da noch einen Bug drin.
Warum zeigt der nur...
Zeigt der immer nur eine Domain an
und nicht mehr?
Oh, ich glaube, ich habe das
an der falschen Stelle drin mit dem Reset.
MonkaS, Alter.
Ich glaube... Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment.
Das muss ich kurz machen, sonst vergesse ich es nachher wieder.
Ähm.
Wo müssen wir da hin?
Internal.
Monitor.
Collector.
Reset.
Hier da, das ist falsch.
Das darf nicht bei Set Value rein.
Oder doch?
Nee, darf es nicht.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Das muss bei Collect.
Bei Collect muss das rein.
glaube ich
oder ich weiß ich keine ahnung das muss ich mir nachher angucken
aber hier aus
Gut.
So, jetzt habe ich euch hier...
Nee, heute Mittag...
Ich weiß, ich sage immer heute Mittag und dann komme ich nicht on.
würde ich gerne mal CacheOS auf der Hardwarekiste ausprobieren.
Achso, ja genau, was ich hier noch zu der Kiste sagen wollte.
Das ist aber noch nicht da.
Wie gesagt, das Ding habe ich bestellt, das steht ja auch schon neben mir.
und das hier ist noch nicht da, weil das wird
erst am, ich weiß nicht, steht hier irgendwie
Versand drin?
Ja, Versand ab 11. Februar.
Das wird erst ab nächster Woche, Mittwoch oder so
verschickt, weil das ist ganz neu.
Das haben die erst vor einer Woche oder so vorgestellt
und ich wollte das direkt
kaufen, als es rausgekommen ist, weil ich mir gedacht habe,
da kriegst du wenigstens noch was.
Aber
ist noch nicht da.
Das heißt, mit dem Nass-Stream
warte ich noch, bis das hier da ist
Und dann werden wir auch mal vergleichen, Stromverbrauch von dem da versus das da.
Weil ganz ehrlich, wenn Leute einfach nur Netzwerkspeicher machen wollen, ist das hier ja auch mehr als genug.
5-Core-CPU, 10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte, reicht dicke.
Ob das jetzt eine 5-Core- oder eine 6-Core-CPU ist, macht es da jetzt nicht so fett.
Wobei das schon ein ganz schön großer Unterschied ist von der Performance her.
Ich würde schon mal sagen, dürfte bestimmt 20% oder so mehr Performance sein oder 30% vielleicht auch.
weil, oder naja, 25, sagen wir mal 25% mehr Performance, sag ich jetzt einfach mal so über den Daumen gepeilt.
Warum? Weil es geht ja nicht um die reine Core-Anzahl, es geht ja auch darum, was das für Cores sind.
Und das hier sind 4 Efficiency-Cores und 1 Performance-Core.
Und das hier sind 4 Efficiency-Cores und 2 Performance-Cores.
also deswegen der eine kern macht tatsächlich schon eine ganze schippe an cpu performance aus
das ist jetzt aber auch nicht so als hätte man hier performance probleme mit also heißt wenn
man das teil hier hat installiert sich dann linux drauf oder in den open media volt oder
einen schulnass oder android oder sonst was und sagt ich will darüber einfach nur sammler shares
machen fürs Netzwerk, da wird das
hier auch reichen. Wobei,
man muss natürlich sagen, je nachdem, was
man machen will, kann es auch
sein, dass es nicht reicht. Also wenn man da
super anspruchsvoll ist und sagt, ja, ich will aber
auch 10 Gig hier
voll saturaten,
hier
sind auch 8 Gig Gramm dabei, oder?
Oder nicht?
Sind denn nicht auch 8 Gig Gramm dabei?
Ich dachte, es sind immer 8 Gig Gramm dabei.
Ist da kein RAM dabei hier?
Also bei meinem
war ein 8GB RAM dabei.
Also bei meinem sind definitiv
8GB RAM dabei gewesen, weil ich hab
den RAM ausgebaut selbst.
Also gut.
4800 plus Amazon.
Ach heute bin ich in Berlin.
Ah, alles klar.
Also bei meinem, wie gesagt, Leute, Waller, Bruder, ich schwör, das hab ich selbst eher 8 GB RAM.
Also bei Amazon, guck mal, bei Amazon kostet er einfach 50 Euro weniger.
Und ist 8 GB RAM dabei.
Also, da würde ich aber auf jeden Fall bei Amazon kaufen, anstatt bei Ugreen selber.
50 Euro weniger und 8 GB RAM dabei.
Ach, Giggram hebt ja den Preis schon mal eine ganze Ecke.
Schauen wir mal, ob es hier auch schon das neue Nass gibt im Store.
Äh, Nass.
Haben wir hier?
4.800 pro gibt's.
The fuck?
Ah, okay, spare 80 Euro mit Rabattgutschein.
Wollte gerade sagen.
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das hier 100 Euro teurer ist.
Ja, 6,99 kostet das.
Also 699
Sind die Ugreen Nass gut?
Das versuche ich rauszufinden
Ich hatte vorher noch nie eins
Oh, ein Dune Fan
Ähm, ich hatte noch nie eins
Ich habe mir jetzt eins bestellt
Und will das mal ausprobieren
Allerdings, ich werde nicht
Das kann ich gleich dazu sagen
Ich werde nicht das Ugreen OS benutzen
Ich werde da Proxmox draufhauen
Wahrscheinlich
Vielleicht wird es auch wieder Unraid
Mal gucken
Also das Ugreen OS
Das kann mir komplett gestohlen bleiben.
Aber hier sind auch 8 Gig.
8 Gig RAM dabei.
Na immerhin, immerhin.
Selbst wenn ich das eine nass nicht brauche,
bleiben die 8 Gig RAM übrig noch.
Ey Leute, ich, ich.
Jugendsprache, ne.
Ihr seid ja teilweise ein bisschen jünger als ich.
Ich bin mittlerweile 41, ne.
Also ich bin richtig old, gell.
Jugendsprache.
Ich war letztens hier in Hanau essen.
Und zwar bei Rooster in Hanau.
Roosterfrei Chicken.
Eigentlich.
Hier, da.
Eigentlich ganz nice.
Ich gehe da gerne hin.
Ich habe schon von Leuten gehört.
Ne, so sieht es da nicht aus.
Ich habe schon von Leuten gehört, dass sie es furchtbar eklig finden oder sowas.
Aber ich finde es da eigentlich ganz gut.
So, zumindest hier war ich letztens futtern.
äh, Rooster Fried Chicken in Hanau
Leute
da saß eine Gruppe Jugendlicher
wie nennt man das heutzutage
Talahohn oder so
Talahohns
ähm, ey
das war so schlimm
das ging die ganze Zeit
also die saßen da zu dritt
die saßen da zu dritt, jeder hat sein Handy
angehabt, jeder hat
irgendwie laufend irgendein Short oder
irgendein Ding geguckt,
zwischendrin, das muss man sich mal vorstellen,
das war so krass cringe,
zwischendrin haben die irgendwelche
Dating-Apps aufgemacht
oder sonst was
und haben dort irgendwelche
Mädels gematcht und der eine
hat dann random mit irgendwie einer dann auch
noch angefangen zu telefonieren, also ganz
ganz furchtbar cringe, zumindest
was aber
abwertende Beschreibung, ja
Dann habe ich auch das Richtige genommen, weil ich finde die auch abwertend, die da gehockt haben.
Ey, und die ganze Zeit, also übernehmen wir dem ganz andere Zeug.
Alter, wie die miteinander geredet haben, das war so krass.
Das ging, also ohne Scheiß, es war, die ganze Zeit bestand aus Wallah und auf Allah, auf Allah.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, Alter, wenn das der Vater hört oder so, wenn der gläubig ist, regt er sich auf.
Die haben permanent gesagt, Wallah auf Allah.
und das ging die ganze zeit zu einer die sind mir so krass auf den sack gegangen
ich hätte gar nicht für möglichkeiten dass die alle so religiös sind alter
früher bei uns was eigentlich eher cool sag ich mal wenn du nicht religiös warst
weil halt so die eltern eher noch so christlich und so was nach dem kinder
gesagt will ich nichts damit zu tun haben aber mittlerweile ist es ja
anscheinend Standard. Alter, die haben wirklich
jeder Satz, jeder zweite Satz
wurde beendet mit Auf Allah!
Auf Allah! Und danach kam Wallah!
Das ging die ganze Zeit so.
Die sind zum Glück nach
knapp, würde ich sagen knapp
Viertelstunde abgehauen.
So richtig war das Essen gerade erst da.
Aber Alter, die sind mir so heftig
auf den Sack gegangen.
Das kann man gar nicht beschreiben, wie krass die mir auf den Sack gegangen sind.
Tja.
Ja, ich kann mit so religiösen Sachen auch nichts anfangen.
Aber ich denke mir, ganz ehrlich, soll jeder machen, worauf er Bock hat.
Oh, shit. Au.
Ich habe gerade was runtergeschmissen, Leute.
Der Quade.
Ich sollte nicht im Zimmer rumlaufen.
Warte mal.
Ich sollte nicht im Zimmer rumlaufen, während ich strebe.
Vor allem nicht, wenn man ein Headset mit Kabel dran hat.
Ich wette mit dir, die waren auch ungebildet.
Zumindest hat sich das alles sehr low IQ mäßig angehört, was sie da gelabert haben.
Und bravo Mike.
So.
Gut.
Da hab ich das auch.
Zack. Rebootet haben wir schon.
Da können wir mal gucken,
was auf GitHub so trendet.
Leute, ich bin so dumm, Alter
Mir ist gerade eingefallen
Warum ein PXE-Boot nicht geht
Oh, ich bin so dumm
Wisst ihr, warum ein PXE-Boot nicht geht?
Oh, Moment
Ich zeig's euch
Mein PXE-Boot geht nicht
Weil ich so schlau war
Und hab mein Boot-Image gelöscht
Für Debian
Für meinen Debian-Installer
Hyperintelligent
Ich hab mein Boot-Image gelöscht
Deswegen bootet er nicht mehr
Aber glücklicherweise
Glücklicherweise waren wir ja so schlau
Und haben das letzte Mal
Das Bild
Für
Hier sind meine Boot Images
Die muss ich jetzt mal wieder drauf kopieren
Was ist das?
Ne
Äh
Hier, Bild, Bildpunkt, das brauchen wir
Okay
Ja, ja
Das, das brauche ich
Äh, ich muss, ich muss meine Boot-Images
Nochmal
Auf die Kiste kopieren
Okay
So, und jetzt sollte ich hier auch Boot-Images liegen haben
Da und da
Und jetzt probieren wir das nochmal
jetzt probieren wir das nochmal
und jetzt funzt das auch gleich, sage ich euch
so, gucken wir mal
Debian Install
es ist vielleicht ein bisschen schlecht benannt, was ich hier gemacht habe
das ist der vollständige Debian Net Installer
mit Preseed File
und das hier ist mein Custom Debian Cloud Image
was viel schneller geht. Jetzt kann ich euch das zeigen,
was ich euch ursprünglich zeigen wollte. Guckt mal,
Leute.
Guckt mal, Leute, wie
schnell ich einen
Debian-Image, eine Debian-VM
am Start habe. Ich hoffe, es funktioniert jetzt,
nachdem ich da meine Boot-Files hingelegt habe.
Install. Ja, von uns.
So. Debian
wird gebootet.
Installer
starten was für ein debian will ich haben ich will debian stable auf diese disk und diese host name
und jetzt passt mal auf schneller habt ihr debian noch nie installiert gesehen wie hier
Debian ist installiert reboot Debian am Start ist das nicht nice so schnell habt ihr noch nie ein Debian Install gesehen
Leute, Forza ist installiert
Guck, und man sieht sogar die IP-Adresse von der VM
Das heißt, das hier ist die 2.0.145
Jetzt kann ich hier auf meine Kiste gehen und sagen
Hier, SSH
1.4.5
Zack
Aha, guck mal da
Mein SSH geht nicht
Weil Key sich geändert hat, jetzt kann ich mein neues
High-IQ-SSH-Kommando benutzen.
Fix SSH. Yes.
Oh, Permission denied.
Debian muss ich benutzen als User.
Und schon sind wir auf der neuen Debian-Kiste drauf.
Also Leute, schneller geht's
beim besten Willen nicht mehr.
Und was auch ganz nice ist,
ich hab sogar Forever-Tools und sowas
alles schon drauf.
Also schneller hast du auch
bei keinem Cloud-Anbieter
deine Debian-VM.
Also bei Hetzner dauert das ungefähr genauso lang,
bis du einen Debian-Server mit Login hast.
Das sind 20-30 Sekunden,
hast du deine Debian-Kiste am Start.
Und da habe ich hart
geskriptet für, dass das so schnell funktioniert.
So, aber was wir jetzt noch machen müssen ist,
wir müssen jetzt noch die Festplatte wieder kaputt machen.
Warum müssen wir die Festplatte wieder kaputt machen?
Dass ich ordentlich PXE-Boot testen kann.
Also, DD.
IF gleich DEF 0.
OF gleich DEF SDA.
Block Size 4M.
Count gleich, naja, 4 reicht.
100, bam.
Was?
Achso.
So.
Und jetzt ist die Festplatte wieder kaputt.
Hoffe ich mal.
Hoffe die Festplatte ist kaputt.
Ja, die Festplatte ist kaputt.
Sehr gut.
Exzellent.
Max of Leak.
Was habe ich wieder geleakt?
Meine IP?
1, 4, 5.
Fuck.
Shit.
Ey, VMware. Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
VMware ist so schlecht geworden.
Mit
25.
Das zeigt teilweise keine Bilder mehr an und sonst was.
Das ist alles so lächerlich.
Ach, du meinst OnlyFans League.
Ja.
Genau. DevSDA ist mein
OnlyFans.
Und was ich übrigens, by the way, auch sehr nice finde, was ich hier eingebaut habe, ist...
Nächstes Projekt, Umstieg auf Proxmox.
Ja, genau.
Was ich hier auch eingebaut habe, was sehr nice ist...
Proxmox, ja, wir probieren das auf dem Nass auf jeden Fall aus.
Habe ich euch ja gerade gezeigt, die Kiste.
Was ich auch sehr nice finde, ist, ich habe hier eine System Rescue CD mit ZFS-Support drauf.
Das heißt, wenn ich mal Probleme mit einer ZFS habe, kann ich einfach das hier booten.
und jetzt wird es noch viel nicer
gleich, passt mal auf
weil man will ja oft nicht vor dem Rechner
der kaputt ist hocken, ja
vielleicht einmal kurz zum PXE booten
aber ich boote jetzt hier mal
PXE und dann
könnt ihr euch angucken
also hier 1.4.5 haben wir die IP
so und dann zeige ich euch
noch was
sobald es gestartet ist
Wie gesagt, auch vom lokalen Server dauert es ein bisschen.
Jetzt wird es im Rescue-CD gebootet.
Und zack.
Startet.
So.
So, und jetzt kann man...
Ich habe da nämlich Boot-Parameter.
Hab da Boot-Parameter eingestellt
Und jetzt kann ich einfach sagen
VNC-Viewer
192.168.2145
Und zack
Guck dir mal da
Hab ich auf einer anderen Linux-Kiste meine Rescue-CD
Per VNC
Ist das nicht nice?
Jetzt kann ich hier drinnen
ZFS
Rescuen
falls ich das brauche.
ZFS. ZFS-List. Gut.
Ich hab noch kein Z... Oh.
What?
Ja, VNC-Stells, Alter.
Richtig nice. Keine Ahnung, was passiert.
Trotzdem richtig nice.
Zpool-List.
Ja, ich mein, ich hab da kein ZFS drauf,
aber passt trotzdem.
Reboot.
No.
Okay, jetzt wird hier wieder
rebooted.
Und vor allem, da zeigt man wieder nichts an.
Aber ich glaube,
das ist schon einer der schönsten
Ja, jetzt zeigt er hier nicht konfiguriert.
Einer der schönsten PXE-Boot-Menüs,
die es gibt, oder?
Mit Katzi am Start.
Auch wenn es eine KI-Katze ist, okay?
Ja, einen Clown-Ziller haben wir auch am Start.
Kann man einfach Backups machen, wenn es sein muss.
Egal, ich habe euch jetzt genug erzählt, wie geil mein PXE-Setup ist.
Warum kein Netboot XYZ? Habe ich doch auch drin, ne?
Oder meinst du, warum überhaupt sowas gebaut?
anstatt direkt netboot xyz benutzt
das ganz einfach warum ich keine boot xyz netboot xyz habe ich natürlich
drin weil es dann noch viel mehr images gibt als das was ich habe falls man das
mal braucht guckt netboot xyz habe ich auch drin aber erstens will ich den
kram lokal haben gut das geht teilweise mit netboot xyz auch ich will ein paar
custom configs haben bei den boot sachen die netboot xyz nicht hat und die hauptsächliche
sache ist eigentlich mein custom ist debian cloud image installer den gibt es in netboot
xyz schlicht und ergreifend nicht da gibt es nur die normalen debian netinstall und kein debian
cloud image install mit cloud init das habe ich ja selbst gebaut und das gibt es in netboot xyz nicht
aber wenn man es braucht kann ich auch ein image bauen das von mehreren
rechnern über netz gebootet werden können und read only ist außer wahr
ja kannst du da gibt es früher gab es da drittel oder wie das hieß keine auch
noch jemand benutzt für für netzwerk gut aber ich habe letztens erst ein projekt
gesehen das hat jemand im stream gepostet dass das hat sich nach genau so was gelesen ich hab's ich
hab's ich habe leider vergessen wie das ding hieß hier netboot oce images irgendwie sowas wie hieß
das denn weiß noch jemand wie dieses projekt hieß hat letzten denkt einer das nenne das ist es mit
px
ich finde dass ich ich habe es habe ich das irgendwie hier gebucht
keine ahnung ich hätte werden wir letztens hatten wir erst einen projekt was genau nach
so was aus wie ich das denn history
ich suche ist ja auch für ein arsch
ist das denn
Bare Metal
Woot OCI Image.
GitHub.
Ah.
Ich finde das nicht mehr.
Das hat letztens einer
hat mich gefragt
Max, kennst du das und das Projekt?
Da habe ich noch gesagt,
nee, kenne ich nicht.
Aber das war genau sowas.
Nee, ich finde das nicht.
Ich habe auch vergessen, wie es heißt.
Irgendwas mit P am Anfang vielleicht?
Nee.
Also falls irgendjemand Ahnung hat, was ich meine,
Boot C?
War das das?
Ja.
Ich glaube, das ist es.
Boot and upgrade via container images.
Das ist ja ungefähr sowas, was du haben willst, glaube ich.
Also ich vermute jetzt einfach mal,
dass das Read-Only ist.
Ja.
Bis auf bestimmte Verzeichnisse.
UC, ja.
Du könntest auch nix OS machen
für Read-Only.
Aber, ehrlich gesagt,
das hab ich mir noch nie...
noch nie Gedanken zu gemacht.
Also, ich mein,
Systeme Read-Only machen an sich ist kein Problem.
Du kannst Root einfach als Read-Only mounten.
Das geht. Das geht schon ewig.
Wir hatten früher Firewalls mit Compact Flashkarte, die waren immer Read-Only gemountet.
Die musstest du immer Read-Write remounten, dass du die Konflikte editieren kannst.
Also Read-Write als Read-Only-Mounten ist kein Problem.
Und du kannst ja theoretisch Root als Read-Only-Mounten und War als Read-Write.
Das sollte tatsächlich out of the box mit den passenden FS-Tab-Entries funktionieren.
vermute ich da jetzt mal so.
So, übrigens, was ich euch noch zeigen wollte,
Netboot XYZ ist natürlich auch am Start.
Das heißt, wenn man Zugriff auf noch mehr Images über PXE braucht,
dann kann ich aus meinem PXE auch einfach Netboot XYZ booten.
Und dann habe ich jetzt wirklich alles Mögliche hier zur Auswahl.
Linux Network Installs für so ziemlich alles, was es gibt.
Linux Live CDs, das meiste, was es gibt.
Man kann sogar BSD installieren, was man eigentlich selten möchte.
Solaris.
Redos.
Sogar Windows.
Funktioniert.
Man hat Sachen wie hier
Clonezilla und Geparted und so noch
Am Start
Also Netboot XYZ habe ich auch eingebaut
Der updatet mir das übrigens auch
Der zieht auch nachts ein neues Image davon
So aber jetzt habe ich hier lange genug
Vmware was ist los
Was ist los Vmware
Ich habe doch gerade gesagt Power Off
Warum macht der nicht Power Off
Jetzt macht der Power Off
Nachdem ich Ctrl Alt Delete gedrückt habe
TemplOS kannst du nicht booten.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob TemplOS überhaupt bootbar ist.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, was auf GitHub so trendet.
Trend.
Mal gucken, ob die GitHub-Trends immer noch so kastriert sind.
Es ist ein bisschen mehr geworden wieder.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
Okay, es sind 12.
Nur war es aber noch mehr, glaube ich.
Es war mal eine Zeit lang nur 8.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was Microsoft auf GitHub wieder treibt.
Also OpenClaw, natürlich.
Was sonst?
AI.
AI?
Keine Ahnung was das ist!
AI? AI?
AI?
Nicht AI.
Okay, was ist das? Agent Orchestration Command Site. Ich hab absolut kein...
AI! Okay, tschüss.
breck wetter pre komit was soll das sein das bestimmte image
aha wie kommit hooks in rust warum genau muss das jetzt den rast sein
weil blazing lieferast ich weiß ja der hat irgendeine lua geschichte für neo
was auch sonst, ja.
So, gucken wir noch mal gerade,
was... Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal...
Wir gucken mal, was im
deutschsprachigen GitHub so trendet, okay?
Das habe ich, glaube ich, noch nie gemacht.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Nix.
Die Germans sind da nicht so...
sind da nicht so am Start, ey.
Okay, okay.
Afrikaans.
Trennt auch nix. Na gut.
Der Fiat Champ ist ein englischsprachiges Repo.
Schauen wir mal,
was bei Go trendet diese Woche.
BitTorrent-Client.
Ah, dass wir unsere Linux-Images runterladen können.
Olamar trendet.
Ja, na gut.
Mermaid, Netbird.
Axon Hub AI.
Was sonst?
Open Telemetry Collector Contrib.
Warum? Was soll ich da collecten?
Zeug.
Das kenne ich. Das sagt mir irgendwas.
Das habe ich schon benutzt.
Was war denn das nochmal?
Irgendein Image Scanner oder sowas?
Irgendein Container-Image-Scanner?
Ah ja, hier.
So was in der Richtung ist das.
Headscale.
Open Source Self-Hosted Implementation of Tailscale.
Oh, das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Kubernetes.
Tailscale.
Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Phone Numbers.
Hackermans.
Crossplane.
Wollte ich auch schon lange mal ausprobieren.
Richtig.
Wobei ich mir jetzt sagen gelassen habe vom Chat,
Oh Lama
ist gar nicht mehr so cool.
Ich habe es mir hier
aufgeschrieben irgendwo, was man
stattdessen verwenden soll für bessere Performance.
Sekunde.
Kobalt CPP.
Kobalt CPP, hat der Chat gesagt.
Chat hat gemeint, das hier ist viel nicer als Ulama.
Kann ich jetzt nicht be- oder entstetigen.
Natürlich erstmal für Anime-KI-Sachen generieren, ist klar.
Soll viel nicer sein.
Gibt es das denn für Windows?
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Gibt es das für Windows?
AI?
Ja.
Gibt es.
Ja, werde ich vielleicht mal ausprobieren.
Aber ich habe gerade aktuell eigentlich keine lokalen Models.
Ich benutze nach wie vor hier.
OpenCode. Und bei OpenCode
gibt es GLM 4.7,
Minimax M2.1
und GPT-5 Nano kostenlos.
Das reicht mir aktuell.
Wobei, Dings hier, Chat,
ähm,
GPT-5.3 kam doch
jetzt raus, oder?
Was für eine
GPT-Version benutze ich
gerade? Da darf man sich
übrigens nicht drauf verlassen. Die Models schreiben
oftmals Mist auf diese Frage hier.
Mit GPT 5.2.
Ich habe nur gelesen, dass GPT 5.3 irgendwie rausgekommen ist letztens.
Ach, Codex.
Das kann man dann nur benutzen mit der...
Mit der Codex CLI oder wie verwendet man das?
Oder wie benutzt man das im Web?
Wie ist Code?
Aber das ist bestimmt auch nicht kostenlos, hä?
Jaja, paid GPT-Plans.
Ganz ehrlich, Jetbrains AI-Features benutze ich erst gar nicht.
Das ist so hakelig und eklig.
Okay, das muss man bezahlen.
Okay, klar, ja.
Na gut.
Dann nicht.
Gemini 3 Pro.
Das würde ich auf der Arbeit gerne benutzen.
Aber wir hängen da irgendwie
mit unseren Lizenzen oder was die sich
da gekauft haben bei Gemini 2.5
Pro oder Flash.
Rum.
Also, das ist immer nicht so aktuell.
So.
Ich will mal noch gucken, was noch
trendet.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Schauen wir mal, was Placing the Fast written in Rust trendet.
Was trendet in Rust?
Breck, das hatten wir schon.
Aber für einen Stream können wir GPT 5.3 Codex testen.
Ja, nee, nicht, wenn man dann einen Account braucht mit Kreditkarte hinterlegt.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Können wir nicht testen.
Ich bin da ja geizig, ich gebe für AI kein Geld aus
Deswegen kann ich auch nicht die besten Models und Ancient Geschiss und sonst was benutzen
Aber ganz ehrlich, für Sachen so wie ich das benutze
Ich benutze das ja immer nur so nach dem Motto
Kann man das hier noch irgendwie schöner machen? Hast du Ideen?
Oder wie würde man das hier in Go machen und sowas?
Ich benutze das eher als Chat als als Agent.
Dafür sind diese Free Models hier wirklich top.
Anki, das gibt es immer noch.
Das gibt es immer noch.
Command Runner, da habe ich letztens ein Video zu gesehen.
Und ich verstehe den Sinn immer noch nicht davon, aber okay.
Ja, der Chat hat mir jetzt letztens versucht zu erklären, was der Sinn davon ist.
Laut OpenAI hat sich 5.3 zum Teil selbst geschrieben.
Ob das so gut funktioniert wie 30% Source-Code bei Microsoft, der von AI programmiert wird
und dann Windows-Rechner fabriziert, die sich nicht mehr runterfahren lassen und sowas.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das ein so großes Qualitätsmerkmal dafür ist.
Hm.
Fischheld rennt in Pingora.
Was sind denn Evolvable Network Services?
Die schreiben das immer so geil in ihre Überschriften rein, aber was ist ein Evolvable Network Service?
Firecracker VMs.
Das habe ich mal ausprobiert.
Okay, das sieht bestimmt hässlich aus.
Bonkers.
Also ein viel hässlicheres Beispiel, um ein UIL-Hybrid zu demonstrieren, hätte man ja kaum nehmen können.
Ich glaube ja, das ist ja cool, dass man da was sehen kann, aber das ist so overloaded.
Check if email exists.
Moment, das geht?
Ohne eine E-Mail zu senden, wie geht das?
Verbinden die sich per SMTP?
Sagen, wo sie es hinschicken wollen und dann...
Wenn der sagt, gibt es nicht?
Oder wie fandest du das?
was ist das war das nicht so ein bootloader macht für android customizing
android an die route access das war das genau
Ein astrologischer CPU-Scheduler.
What the...
Core Utils written in Rust.
Auf der einen Seite cool, auf der anderen Seite auch irgendwie was, was die Welt nicht gebraucht hat.
AI.
Rust Desk.
Monitor your Internet Traffic.
nur shell lands die b so als letztes gucke ich jetzt noch was bei sich abtrennt dann
haben wir alles durch was mich interessiert uni get ui graphical interface for your package
managers ist es ein wind jetzt in windet ja sowas in der richtung besser besser als das
Microsoft-Ding.
Ja, reines Internet.
Reines Windows-Stells.
Winget UI.
Okay, das ist aber tatsächlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Weil ich weiß nicht, wie Microsoft
das geschafft hat, die Bedienung von Winget
zackt. Es gab so viele
Package-Manager, wo man sich was abgucken konnte.
Allein schon da was zu finden.
terraria mods powershell trendet der terraria stellt ist ein voll angesagt gerade github
actions runner ach der sind sie scharprogrammiert muss gar nicht noch net die bagger
beziehungsweise eigentlich ist das was wohl so zum die kopf heilen bald krepp an installer
removes large marktes für windows kam bett okay get against impact hacks
es bei wo ich auch den sinn davon noch nicht verstanden habe
bit one server
also ganz ehrlich da war jetzt auch nicht wirklich viel spannendes kann das hier ordentlich youtube
mittlerweile downloaden so bald grab installer an installer looking for maintenance geht schon
gut los okay das sind die github trends gewiss naja so viel spannendes war diese woche nicht
dabei weil sie wird man wieder zeit für product placement dazu müsste ich
überhaupt erst mal videos machen dass ich wieder product placement machen kann
ohne videos keine product placement
So.
Also.
Dann gucken wir doch mal.
Irgendwas auf YouTube.
Read me. Very important.
Gehört zu
Comfy UI.
Das hab ich, glaub ich, schon mal aufgefallen.
So, gucken wir mal, was auf YouTube so trendet.
Steve Ball macht's
craziest moments.
Ne, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Dass der Kerl sie nicht mehr alle hat, ist glaube ich klar.
Die Wellerpost, die Wellerpost, die Wellerpost, die Wellerpost.
Sicherheitslücke in Passwortmanagern.
Tja, wer hätte das gedacht? Zeig mal her.
Passwortmanager können extrem leicht gehackt werden.
Auf der Hackerkonferenz DEVCON, auf der auch gerne mal das FBI neue Hacker anwirbt, mutmaßlich,
wurde dom basiertes extension klick checking vorgestellt
aha das ist das klingt nach browser adon geschichten
eine einzige bösartige seite und maximal ein klick von dir und deine kreditkarten
daten deine gespeicherten persönlichen daten und sogar passwörter totps und
passkey ja gut ich benutze im browser kein passwort manager extensions können
einfach abgegriffen werden und das für fast alle passwort manager
Ja, Keypass ist aber nicht drin.
Naja, wie gesagt, ich benutze ja keine Browser-Add-ons.
Einzig Dashlane sah nicht komplett furchtbar aus.
Die gute Nachricht, einige Passwortmanager wie Proton oder Nordpass sind schon repariert.
Mein Bitwarden ist in Progress.
Aber ihr könnt auch selbst aktiv werden.
Wenn ihr automatisches Ausfüllen deaktiviert, ist der Angriff komplett unwirksam.
Nur müsst ihr dann halt wieder wie ein Höhlenmensch copy-pasten.
Ja und? Ja und?
Es ist doch nicht so, dass man im Sekundentakt Passwörter eintippt.
Ich copy-paste immer.
Das ist doch schon alt.
Das ist fünf Monate her.
Keck, wait, Alter.
Warum ist der YouTube der Meinung, dieser Short ist jetzt super angesagt?
Also...
Ach stimmt, Opus 4.6 kam ja auch raus.
Also die Videoempfehlungen sind jetzt auch nicht so dolle.
Du hast auf, du hast auf, äh, was, Moment, auf Reddit gelesen.
Wie viel Scheiße hier eigentlich im Hintergrund läuft mittlerweile
Auch bei Windows 11, ne?
Guckt euch das mal an
Massive Cagweight
Äh, ich hab gelesen
YouTube will nicht mal das Upload-Datum
Was?
Es gibt schon keine Daumen runter mehr
Was auch mega fail ist
Jetzt will ich doch nicht mal das Upload-Datum anzeigen
Machst ein Video auf
Denkst dir hier, top, aktuelle Sicherheitslücke
Bla, ja, sechs Jahre
da musst du in die comments gucken oder so dumm alter so dumm
mit youtube upload date
haben wir dann hier interview with just use vps pro ok den
gucke ich normalerweise nicht aber das sah auf den ersten blick gar nicht so
gar nicht so übel aus was was haben wir hier
Ah, exzellent Schlürfgeräusche.
Okay, that was easy.
Let's start by splitting up a server on your cloud VPS provider.
You know, just a 1G CPU, 4GB RAM.
Aber mit einer CPU kommt er noch nicht sonderlich weit.
100GB Drive.
Then you'll get a public IP and root SSH access.
Then immediately we're under attack.
Das stimmt.
I haven't even logged in yet.
Ja, SSH-Scan started 12 seconds ago.
Now it's a fight against time.
Do not install anything before securing your VPS and RUID SSH access.
So first we make sure we have the latest data of the internet on our VPS.
With APATA update and APATA upgrade why?
Why?
Our job is to keep our core running while other packages are changing theirs.
Then we'll install essential security networking tools.
APATA.
CURL.
WGET.
UFW.
VELTABAN.
CA certificates.
GNUG.
G.
Why weren't these installed by default?
Das ist eigentlich gar kein schlechtes Tutorial.
weil es stimmt ja alles
Und was brauche ich?
Das ist eine Frage.
Lass uns mal schauen, was das Tutorial sagt.
Das Tutorial wird es nicht nennen, weil ich das Tutorial geschrieben habe.
Wir blockieren alle unverantwortlichen Traffik von der weltweiten hostilen App.
Aber wir lassen eine Tür offen.
Port 2222.
Dann aktivieren wir die Feuerwalle.
Warum 4 2?
Oh, es ist nur ein arbitrarier Nummer.
Aber es scheidet trotzdem nichts.
brauche man zwar nicht wirklich aber
Ah, White Loss
Jetzt erlauben wir SSH nur für Port 2022, aber verpackt durch unsere private VPN-Masch.
Publische SSH ist jetzt weg.
Alle öffentlichen Inbound-Traffic ist jetzt weg.
Außer future IPv6-Geschrei.
Also erheben wir IPv6 in UofW und verabschieden die Kern-Anwendungen.
Nicht nur, damit wir besser schlafen können.
Verladen. Verifizieren.
Und natürlich irgendwelche Sachen
Bash nach sudo sh-Pipen.
Verifiziere die Repo und Kompromisse durch Github und 900 random NPM Abhängigkeiten.
Währenddessen kreieren wir eine Kredenz-Direktorie.
Weil wir Produktion-Apps nicht ins Haus bringen können wie verrückte Menschen.
Dann fixieren wir die Direktore-Vorstellungen.
Warum sind sie kaputt?
Kaputt ist der Defacto-Standard.
Starten, wieder starten und die User-Package mit Status verifizieren.
Also wenn man das sieht, könnte man fast denken,
in Linux Server aufzusetzen ist Wissenschaft für sich.
Nein, mit Doktor.
And now we are done.
We configure the systemd-Service, so if it breaks, it doesn't crash.
You know, systemd is a controversial idea that hasn't been recognized widely in the Linux community
because initially it started as an init-System, then it became a Schedule, a Debugger, a Login Manager,
a Device Manager, a Process Manager.
So if it crashes, basically everything crashes.
But since 2015, basically every major Linux distribution has decided for this argument in 2015
und we lost.
But there are still people who use R-Units,
you know, OpMARC or S6,
but, you know, we don't talk to these people.
But for now, SystemD is an optimal,
but, you know...
Das heißt R-Unit, ich habe überlegt, das heißt RunIt.
...non-optimal solution.
We don't have anything to say? Okay.
So, we create this small unit file,
activate and reactivate
the service. Now make sure
we're logging everything to observe runtime behavior.
Disk protection, backups,
backups, and then
Run your application security audit.
If it has one.
I love it.
I thought we did security already.
No, no.
You don't do security.
Security needs to live rent-free in your mind at all times.
And now you have the setup with no public SSH,
no public web ports,
and server-only reachable via tailscale.
98.1% uptime.
If you ignore the weekly kernel panics.
Und das war einfach?
Ja, das war die Ubuntu-Version.
Jetzt kann ich dir zeigen, wie du das auf Arch machen würdest, übrigens.
Nein, nein, danke. Aber jetzt sind wir bereit.
Nun kannst du die App-Sicherheitsmessungen konfigurieren,
damit es nicht dein Gmail-Ethereum-Wallet verlässt,
und du kannst online anrufen, wenn jemand ein Wort schreibt,
wenn du deine Telegram-Bot anrufen kannst.
Welche VPS hast du?
er war schon viel wahres dabei
irgendwie sind die empfehlungen heute ziemlich
Ja, das meiste davon brauchst du nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde mir
auf einem Public Server, ich hab mir da noch nie
ein Tailscale-Zeug...
Ich, ganz ehrlich, ich würde mir auch
nicht einfach auf jedem Linux-Server ein Tailscale
einrichten warum mein ssh auf port 22 22 ok kann man machen
ssh mit kies ist mir sicher genug hast du dich schon über das entfernen der
listenansicht im youtube so viel aufgeregt ist das jetzt auch weg meine
güte youtube geht mir auf den sack
Ich muss mich outen.
Ich habe Tailscale noch nie benutzt.
Chat.
Wer kann das hier beantworten?
Was ist der Vorteil von Tailscale
versus klassischem VPN?
Also, was ich mir so spontan denke, ist,
das Beste an Tailscale ist,
dass das Setup einfacher ist,
als wenn man sich selbst in OpenVPN
und sowas zusammenwurschtelt.
ok carrier kreis ja verstehe ich leuchte mir auch ein ja
kein feierabend seuchs und duals tag ist egal
Okay.
Wie ist das denn mit Talescale?
Hätte dann Cloudflare theoretisch
vollen Zugriff auf deinen Server?
Wenn sie wollten?
Ja, Wireguard ist angesagter
als OpenVPN, das stimmt.
so was haben wir denn sonst noch hier
microsoft fixe drittler ganz bestimmt nicht
zusammen hier am start selbst aus dem pass kiesel moment das ist doch ein deutsches video sag mal
Jetzt mal Chat, Chat, ernsthaft.
Geht euch dieses automatische Übersetzer auch überall so auf den Sack?
Also es ist ja nicht nur YouTube, auf Reddit ist das auch so.
Du landest teilweise auf Reddit und denkst dir, alter schreiben die heute wieder dumm.
Und dann checkst du irgendwann, ah ok, das ist ja in einer ganz anderen Sprache ursprünglich gewesen.
Ja, ok, euch geht das auch auf den Sack.
Mein Browser steht auf Englisch
Jetzt werden teilweise deutsche Sachen auf Englisch übersetzt
Auch geil
Dagegen gibt es ein Addon
Es ist scheiße, dass man das braucht
Kann man dann wenigstens opt-outen irgendwie auf Reddit?
Wenn man eingeloggt ist
Gibt es da ein opt-out Super Reddit vielleicht?
Ich glaube nicht
youtube an die treue und für reddit auch
red antwort slater
das ist halt alles aber richtig dumm wir sollen das einfach in ruhe lassen ich meine ich hätte
ja gar keine möglichkeit der probleme mit wenson ventures feature prinzipiell gibt und meinetwegen
meinetwegen wenn sich die teams keine blöße geben wollen dass es doch nicht so geil ist meinetwegen
kann es sogar an bei default sein aber lasst es einfach opt outen ja also lasst einfach ausschalten
ausschaltbar und am besten speichert er sich das im browser ohne dass man eingeloggt sein muss
ja
genau erst mal englisch test machen vor gucken was das mal hier was gibt's denn hier also
self hosting passki on your own server das interessiert mich in der tat
paski ist an sich war es was mich schon eine ganze weile interessiert aber ich hatte bisher
keinen bock drauf dass über irgendwelche apple cloud sachen zu suchen und sonst was also ein
passki ist quasi ein ersatz für passwörter der auf public und private key sachen so ähnlich wie
bei SSH basiert.
Aber
ich hab's selbst noch nie ausprobiert.
Wenn man das selbst hosten kann, klingt nett
verkehrt.
Bestimmt Waldwarden.
Waldwarden.
Waldwarden. Meine Güte.
Also ich bleib bei KeyPass.
Okay, gucken wir uns das mal an.
jetzt nicht mehr auf den großen hersteller cloud sondern die liegen total entspannt auf meinem
eigenen home server und als backup noch in dieser kiepass datei alles open source alles lokal und
vor allem alles super sicher in unserem letzten video zu passkies haben wir das problem ja schon
angesprochen viele anbieter wie apple und google bieten zwar einen einfachen sinkt also eine sache
die ich also eines der wenigen sachen die ich tatsächlich so was passwörter angeht sowas über
die Cloud Sync sind meine zwei Faktor Authentifizierungstokens. Ich benutze dafür
EnterAuth. Kennt das jemand von euch? Das ist eigentlich recht verbreitet glaube ich.
EnterAuth und die haben eine kostenlose, kostenlosen Cloud Sync und die sagen es
ist per passwort end-to-end encrypted das heißt sie können das auch nicht lesen muss man ihnen
glauben aber mal ganz im ernst reihe mit reiner zwei faktor authentifizierung kann ja auch keiner
was anfangen also das ist so das kann ich noch vertreten ja und leute wer bisher kein backup
das kann jetzt nur eindrücklich sagen ja wer kein backup von seinen zwei faktor authentifizierung
hat oder zumindest in sync dass man es auf mehreren geräten benutzen kann und dort noch
zugriff hat sollte das unbedingt machen ein backup von seinen zwei faktor authentifizierung
stoppens unbedingt weil die chance sich selbst aus seinen eigenen accounts auszusperren wenn
man mal das handy verliert überfallen wird in frankfurt oder sonst was passiert mit dem handy
ist sehr hoch.
Also,
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
ist nicht nur ein zweiter Faktor bei der
Anmeldung,
die sich irgendwelche Leute,
die sich Zugang zu eurem Account verschaffen wollen,
haben müssen.
Nee, es ist auch für euch.
Also, es haben schon sehr viele Leute den Zugang
zu Accounts verloren, weil ihre
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-App nicht mehr ginge.
Ich hatte selbst so ein ähnliches Problem.
Ich habe früher,
habe ich hier
2FA
Ravio hieß das,
benutzt.
Und das war eigentlich eine ganz
coole App. Das ist der Vorgänger quasi
von EnterAuth, so ein bisschen.
So, und das
Ding ist, der Typ hat
das irgendwann mal verkauft.
Der hat die
Anwendung verkauft.
Und
von einem Tag auf den
anderen
hatte ich keine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungskies mehr.
Weil die App hat sich über den App Store geupdatet
und danach haben die irgendwas verkackt beim Update
und ich hatte keinen Backup.
Da habe ich geguckt.
Wisst ihr, was ich dann gemacht habe?
Aus der Not heraus, also glücklicherweise habe ich für die meisten Sachen
noch hier einen Zettel liegen mit Einmal-Codes,
Wobei das natürlich auch nicht bei allem funktioniert.
Was ich dann gemacht habe ist, was ganz furchtbar abenteuerliches.
Ich habe auf meinem iPhone die App downgraded zu einer Version, die noch ging und dann habe ich damit exportiert.
Leute, hat jemand von euch schon mal unter iOS eine App downgraded?
Das ist so ziemlich der beschissenste Prozess, den man sich vorstellen kann.
Man braucht iTunes, das geht.
Man braucht iTunes, man braucht einen Man-in-the-Middle-Proxy und man muss irgendwelche Sachen on the fly rewriten. Ganz, ganz abartig. Sachen downcrain. Richtig hardcore abartig. Das habe ich aber geschafft, dann habe ich mein Kram exportiert und seitdem benutze ich EnterOS. Ich habe den Fehler gemacht, zwischendurch den Microsoft Authenticator zu benutzen, weil ich EnterOS noch nicht kannte. Da muss ich nochmal umstellen.
So. Wie kannst du Google Authenticator 2FA Backupen? Keine Ahnung, ob da was eingebaut ist. Ich würde prinzipiell auch keine 2FA Anwendung benutzen, die es nicht erlaubt, die Sachen zu exportieren.
Letztendlich macht ja so eine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-App nichts großartig Kompliziertes.
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Ihr erinnert euch ja dran, wenn ihr das einrichtet, müsst ihr immer so ein QR-Code scannen.
Was in diesem QR-Code drin steht, sind zwei Sachen.
Das OTP, also das Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-Generierungsverfahren und ein Shared-Secret.
Und anhand von diesen Infos, das scannt ihr dann mit der App.
Und anhand dieser Infos und der aktuellen Uhrzeit können dann Server und euer Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-Client unabhängig voneinander quasi das gleiche Token berechnen.
So, letztendlich bei so einem Export von so einer Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-App brauchst du einfach nur, müsste das Ding einfach nur eine Textdatei rausschreiben mit Shared Secrets und Verfahren. Fertig.
das ist alles, mehr musst du das nicht machen
das ist, also ohne Scheiß
zwei Faktor, ist nichts kompliziertes
und der Microsoft
Authenticator kann das nicht
der kann das nur über irgendwelche komischen
Cloud Backup Sachen und so
es ist so dumm, so dumm gemacht
auch so ein Ding ist
ich benutze Ente, Ente Auth
Ente Auth heißt das
das benutze ich
was auch so ein Ding ist,
Sachen wie beispielsweise
Blizzard Authenticator.
Was machst du,
wenn,
Blizzard unterstützt nur ihre eigene Authenticator-App,
ne? Was machst du,
wenn
dein Handy geklaut wird?
Wie sagt,
du kannst dir auch die QR-Codes
wegsamen. Noch einfacher,
du kannst dir einfach das Shared-Secret aus dem
QR-Code speichern. Aber du kannst ja auch die
QR-Code safen. Ja, ja, das geht.
Klar.
Disfunst.
Wobei es halt ein bisschen fraglich ist,
muss man auch dazu sagen. Es ist ein bisschen
fraglich, wenn man Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
macht und dann die
Informationen für die Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
auf dem gleichen Gerät speichert, wo man auch
quasi seinen ersten Faktor speichert.
Das ist dann vielleicht ein bisschen fragwürdig, ob das so sinnvoll ist,
da noch überhaupt Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
zu machen.
Also wenn man jetzt sagt, okay,
Ich habe einen Passwort-Save, speichere dort drin Passwörter und zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung und jemand bekommt Zugang zum Passwort-Save.
Also dann gibt es keinen zweiten Faktor.
In dem Sinn.
Also da kann man sich tatsächlich, ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Deswegen habe ich meine One-Time-Passwörter, habe ich tatsächlich ausgedruckt hier liegen.
Also ich habe die ausgedruckt hier liegen, wenn ich beispielsweise für YouTube oder GitHub oder so mal wirklich zwei Faktor Authentifizierung verliere und es irgendwie resetten müsste, dann kann ich das damit machen.
L
Turco 10, schön, dass du am Start bist
Pog, ja, also wie gesagt
das Ding finde ich persönlich sehr gut
gibt es für IOS
und gibt es glaube ich auch für
Android
sogar für das iPad und sowas
für Windows, für Linux
für so ziemlich alles
gibt es Anthos
und die haben eine kostenlose
Cloud zum Syncen
Da ist natürlich dann immer die Frage, also ihr wisst ja, wie das ist, wenn was kostenlos ist, bist du das Produkt, aber die versuchen natürlich ihren Photosync-Service und Online-Speicher zu verkaufen und zu Geld zu machen, heißt im Endeffekt, die haben ein Geschäftsmodell dahinter, was irgendwie auch einleuchtet, also ja, ich glaube denen einfach mal, dass die es nicht lesen können, letztendlich weißt du das natürlich nicht, ja.
Der Hersteller sagt, ey, guck mal, du kannst ein Passwort eingeben, mit dem deine OTPs verschlüsselt werden. Das kennen wir nicht und wir haben keine Möglichkeit, darauf zuzugreifen, end-to-end verschlüsselt. Das sagen die. Letztendlich kannst du ja nicht reingucken, was die App wirklich macht.
Ein weiterer Pluspunkt ist, die Sachen sind alle hier Open Source. Da ist es aber auch so, streng genommen, selbst wenn eine App oder eine Software Open Source ist, heißt das noch, also zwei Sachen. Heißt erstens, noch lange nicht, dass da drin keine Security-fragwürdigen Dinger passieren. Da müsste erstmal einer reviewen.
Und das nächste, was viel schwerer wirkt, ist, du kannst nicht mit Sicherheit sagen, in der Regel zumindest, dass das, was du hier in diesem Open Source Repo siehst, auch wirklich das ist, was du aus dem App Store installierst. Das könntest du nur, wenn du dir die Sache selbst runterlädst, selbst kompilierst und selbst auf dein Handy schiebst, was ja bei Apple nicht richtig funktioniert. Also du kannst nicht sicher sein, dass das, was du hier Open Source auf GitHub siehst, auch das ist, was du aus dem App Store runterlädst.
Also im Prinzip ist das Trust Me Pro.
Ich glaub's Ihnen mal,
aber auf der anderen Seite ist
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung für sich genommen
auch nicht
so kritisch, weil
da sind ja keine Passwörter dabei.
Also mit Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung allein
kann keiner was anfangen.
Ja, also
so ist es.
Enter Off gibt es für,
was ich übrigens sehr nice finde,
äh
gibt es für Windows, Linux,
Apple, Android, äh, nee das ist Mac oder?
DMG ist Mac.
Aber es gibt es auch für iOS.
Also das ist schon in der Tat sehr nice, eine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung-App, die es für alles gibt. Muss man aber sagen, ist natürlich auch wieder mit ein bisschen Vorsicht zu genießen. Da fehlt mir ganz ehrlich, da fehlt mir die iOS-App. Das ist ja eine reine Web-Anwendung.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ja, ist natürlich auch ein bisschen mit Vorsicht zu genießen
Die haben iOS, wirklich?
Tatsächlich? Okay
Es ist natürlich auch ein bisschen mit Vorsicht zu genießen
Wenn man eine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-App
Auf dem gleichen Gerät hat
Wie auch den ersten Faktor
Also habt ihr euren Passwort-Save und eure Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-App auf dem gleichen PC.
Ja, also wenn jemand es schafft, bei euch irgendein Backdoor-Zeug einzuschleusen, dann hat er wahrscheinlich mit kurz oder langem Zugriff auf beides.
Deswegen ist der eigentliche Ansatz von Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung, das mit dem Handy zu machen, finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Aber es muss unbedingt gebackupt sein, sonst sperrt ihr euch irgendwann früher oder später nochmal selbst aus.
Kennst du Hey Login? Nee, kenn ich nicht.
Okay, jetzt muss ich auch mal gucken.
Was die haben tatsächlich.
Was war das denn?
Irgendeine Insel?
Eiffa Königreich. Alles klar.
GitHub.
Und die haben...
Ach, guck mal, die haben eine iOS-App.
Das wusste ich ja gar nicht.
Ich dachte, das ist eine reine Web-Anwendung.
Ich dachte, das ist eine reine
Web-Anwendung
Das heißt, man kann das selbst hosten
Damit, dann
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ach ja
Und das gibt es auch
Das gibt es auch ganz normal in App Store, oder?
Das ist in der Tat recht nice.
Wie hostet man sich das selbst?
Ach, das ist eine Go-Anwendung.
Das ist einfach nur ein Binary, oder?
Es gibt keine Releases.
und wie selbst hauste ich das jetzt?
Muss ich das selbst kompilieren?
War jetzt bei der Go-Anwendung
auch nicht so schwierig.
Was ist der Vorteil
zu Ente, dass du selbst hosten kannst?
Du kannst Ente zwar auch
selbst hosten, aber das ist ein ziemlich großer Stack.
Ist das einfach nicht nur der Client?
Es heißt 2FA Server.
Ich würde mal sagen...
Wieso hosten?
Für Sync.
Es geht mir um den Sync.
Das hier ist der Client und das hier ist der Server.
Heißt im Endeffekt, man kann seine Geräte syncen.
Zwei Faktor Authentifizierung.
Ich kann es beispielsweise von meinem iPhone aufs iPad syncen.
Und ich habe damit noch ein Backup.
Auch wenn Sync kein, was nicht wirklich Backup ist, aber dafür ist okay.
Also ein fertiges Docker-Image.
Das kann natürlich sein.
Die haben Docker-Compose-Jammel am Start.
Boah, da musst du ja auch wieder 30 Milliarden Sachen laufen lassen.
Ja, das fuckt mich schon wieder ab.
Haben sie eine Go-Anwendung und brauchst wieder 30 Sachen da, ey.
Muss laufen lassen hier.
api ist ein eigener endpunkt hat man das ein eigener endpunkt websocket das
eigene msql redis die dinge sind immer ausgelegt auf super viele user und sonst
was das brauche ich bei mir daheim überhaupt nicht
was issues 2 da gibt es gibt es was zu gucken
Seit wann passt denn da die Adressleiste nicht mehr angepasst mit den Issues?
Ne, ne, aber normalerweise wird die Adressleiste angepasst.
Ich wollte einfach 2 eingeben.
Warum einfach kein File in iCloud, Nextcloud und dann auch aus der Datei synchen?
Ich mach doch, kann man auch, kann man auch.
Das kenn ich gar nicht.
OTP-Auth, was ist das?
OTP off.
So.
Kann man auch machen.
Find ich auch nicht schlecht.
Aktuell auf der Arbeit mache, letzte Woche
war ich auf einem
so Art Teambuilding Workshop.
Da wurden wir wieder
gequält mit irgendwelchen Spielchen.
Ne, stimmt nicht.
Wir haben keine Spielchen gemacht.
Wir haben ganz viele Sachen zum Mitmachen
gemacht, aber es ging.
Es war gar nicht so schlimm.
Ich hatte erst am Anfang überhaupt keinen Bock drauf, aber so im Laufe des Tages ging es dann halbwegs.
Random Max gefunden, ja, ich bin auch am Start.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, bevor jetzt wieder der Chat wieder anfängt, ich habe lange keine Videos mehr gemacht.
Ihr musstet mal ein Haus aus Nudeln bauen bei diesem Event.
Also was wir schon gemacht haben auf diesen Events ist, mach ich mal kurz ein bisschen Musik an.
Was wir bei diesen Events schon gemacht haben, ist...
Lass mal gucken.
An was kann ich mich erinnern?
Wir haben den Tower of Power gemacht.
Kennt jemand den Tower of Power?
Das ist so ein Spiel mit Klötzchen.
So was ist das hier.
Guck genau.
So was.
Das hier ist es.
Tower of Power.
Das ist die einfache Version.
Wir hatten das mit schrägen...
Wir hatten das hier mit schrägen...
Ähm...
Dingern.
Genau.
Tower of Power.
Ja.
Jeder kriegt das Ende von so einem Kran.
und dann muss das aufeinander gestapelt werden.
Power of Power haben wir gemacht.
Dann haben wir gemacht
Teambuilding
der Säuresee. Mal gucken, ob man
das da auch findet.
Ja, genau.
Teambuilding Säuresee.
Eine Gruppe muss einen Gegenstand
aus der Mitte eines durch ein Seil markierten
Kreises bergen, ohne den Boden innerhalb des
Kreises zu berühren.
Der Säuresee.
Dann haben wir zusammen mit verbundenen Augen
Zelte aufgebaut.
und und dinge ich will gar nicht das ist diese deswegen bin ich auch überzeugt es
muss trainer trainings geben wo solche dinge sich weiter verbreiten weil das
können die sich nicht alles selbst ausdenken immer das ist das ist richtig
da ist auf grün stieße dinge und hier da ist auf grün
ja diese spielchen sind schon recht schlimm aber da muss man ab und zu mal
durch und es kann auch das tal auslohnt du planst du potz self hosting
Ah, da gibt es sogar ein Docker-Image.
Aha, nice.
Was ist das?
Das ist nochmal was anderes.
Ach, das hier meinte ich.
Das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte.
Das ist nur eine Web-Anwendung.
Na gut.
So, dann gucken wir mal.
Ich wollte mir das hier angucken.
Was, ähm, genau.
Alternative zu Passkeys.
Gucken wir uns das an.
Ich wurde hardcore sidetracked.
Guck mal hier, meine Passkeys
chillen jetzt nicht mehr auf den großen Hersteller-Clouds,
sondern die liegen total entspannt auf meinem eigenen Homeserver
und als Backup noch in dieser
Keypass-Datei. Alles open source,
alles lokal und vor allem...
Chat, Chat, eine Sache, die mir gerade einfällt. Wisst ihr,
wenn wir uns Linux installieren auf diesem
Mini-PC und ich Linux verwende
anstatt meiner VM, dann kann ich keine
Bilder mehr overlayen.
Das sagt,
da gibt es nämlich zwei
Probleme. Das erste
Problem ist, diese Bilder
Overlay-Anwendung, die ich hier gebaut habe, die ist
Windows-only, weil die benutzt WPF.
das nächste problem ist dass ich wetten könnte ich könnte wetten das funktioniert nicht mit
wayland selbst wenn ich mir da was bauen würde auf nicht-wpf basis das wird nicht mit wayland
funktionieren weil wayland bei sowas abfuck ist das geht bestimmt nicht
Du kannst es als Websource in OBS rein. Das kann meine Anwendung sogar schon,
aber ich will es ja nicht in OBS haben. Also ich habe einen Web Endpunkt für die Anwendung,
kann das schon ja, aber ich will ja die Bilder selber sehen und das sehe ich mit einer Websource
nicht
weyland overlay transparent image etwas
und das große preisfragen
Das ist einer der Weyland vs. X Pain Points.
Jetzt gucken wir uns das aber echt an.
Und wenn ich auf dem zweiten Monitor,
was mir auch noch einfällt, wenn ich auf dem zweiten
Monitor da eine Linux-Kiste hab, anstatt
hier, dann hab ich ja gar kein Monitor
mehr frei, um
meine Emotes und Dinger und
und Zeug
zu fernsteuern.
Du willst wohl weg von Windows und
Nee, ich will nicht weg.
Ich will nicht weg. Der Grund, warum ich das mache, ist folgender. Ich sehe es halt am Horizont so langsam, aber sicher, dass, ich meine, X ist jetzt schon nur noch sehr stiefmütterlich behandelt. Ich sehe es halt so am Horizont schon kommen, dass immer mehr Distributionen den X-Support einstellen werden in den kommenden Jahren.
und dementsprechend auch
Sachen, die auf X aufsetzen, immer weniger Updates
und sonst was bekommen, also
ich sehe halt einfach, dass X
schon
so angezählt ist
auch wenn es mich ein bisschen abfuckt, weil
das Setup mit Abstand am besten
funktioniert, das ist für mich echt das
Beste, Performance ist okay in der
VM, sogar unter Windows 11
mit dem Windows Shit
das auf dem zweiten Desktop haben, ist halt
sehr praktisch. Performance ist
auch okay. Die einzige Performance, die nicht gut ist,
ist Videos gucken, aber ich gucke kaum Videos
in der VM. Wobei selbst das funktioniert
ohne Scheiß. Selbst das Funst in der VM
halbwegs gut, ja.
Wayland unter VM funktioniert nicht richtig.
Wayland unter VM, ja.
Das einzige, was da ganz brauchbar funktioniert,
ist Plasma, KDE.
Aber auch das hat
Probleme.
Ja, also hier Videos.
Videos funktionieren schon in der VM,
ja, aber das
verursacht halt schon einiges CPU-Last,
weil halt kein Hardware-Video-Decoding.
Guck mal, ich hab 4K-Abo
verloren, weil ich so viel inaktiv war.
So inaktiv war.
Aber so ist das halt,
kann man sich nicht beschweren.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal
das Video.
Guck mal hier,
meine Passkeys chillen.
Ja, das haben wir jetzt dreimal gehört schon.
Clouds, sondern die liegen total entspannt auf meinem eigenen Home-Server und als Backup noch
in dieser KeyPass-Datei. Alles open source, alles lokal und vor allem alles super sicher.
In unserem letzten Video zu Passkeys haben wir das Problem ja schon angesprochen. Viele Anbieter
wie Apple und Google bieten zwar einen einfachen Sync eurer Passkeys an, allerdings nur auf ihrer
eigenen Plattform. Klar, wir haben da auch schon so ein paar Lösungen gezeigt, aber in diesem Video
gehen wir noch einen Schritt weiter. Wir zeigen
hier, wie man Parsky wirklich
lokal speichert, also
ohne große Cloud. Und in diesem
Video beschäftigen wir uns auch... YouTube hat ein Video-Auto-Übersetz.
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal anhören.
Wie mein Video-Auto-Übersetz sich anhört.
Stimmt.
Kann das... Ich frag mich halt, ob das auch
Audio...
Ah, Moment. Ich hab kein Audio hier in meiner
VM. Ja, brauch ich normalerweise auch nicht.
Ah nee, Subtitles geht, okay
German auto-generated
What the fuck
Das Video ist in German, Alter
Ach jetzt ist es wieder auf Deutsch
Meine Güte, YouTube, Alter
Wäre das Video hier jetzt auf Englisch gerade?
Oder ist das Gelaber weiter auf Deutsch?
Ich habe hier kein Audio installiert.
Wir gucken jetzt das Video fertig.
Mit der Möglichkeit, wie ihr die auf dem eigenen Home-Server posten könnt.
Ihr habt ja immer gefragt, was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich meinen Passkey verloren habe?
Und ja, da ihr mehrere Passkeys für einen Account erstellen könnt, könnt ihr eben auch easy eine Datei anlegen, in der einfach Backups von allen wichtigen Zugängen drin sind.
Wie das genau geht, bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerinnen...
Wann malen die dann auch in Bitwarden speichern, Passkeys? Ich weiß es nicht.
Also, bauchgefühlmäßig würde ich mal vermuten, das geht.
Aber ich habe Bitwarden ja noch nicht großartig verwendet, also weiß ich nicht.
Achso, ja, ist jetzt ein Video mal ohne...
Ja, ja, wir können auch Videos ohne KI.
Ja, und Linux kommt auch nicht vor.
Was? Kein Linux? Keine KI? Was ist da los?
Herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Mit Premium hast du auch zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung in Bitwarden.
Und wie ist das, wenn man sich das selbst hostet mit Vault Warden oder Bitwarden Lite oder was es da gibt?
Weil ein Abo für 2FA will ich nicht abschließen.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, wo wir wieder bei dem eigentlichen Punkt sind, 2FA und Passwörter in der gleichen App, beziehungsweise auf dem gleichen Gerät, macht ja eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Da kann man sich zwei Faktor-Annotifizierung aussparen.
Apropos anmelden mit...
Hinweis noch aus dem heißen Universum.
Mein lieber Kollege Jörg macht ja den YouTube-Channel Phasenlage, wo es um die Energiewende geht.
Da könnt ihr Videos sehen zu Themen wie Balkonsolar. Guckt doch mal in die Beschreibung, da ist der Link.
Ganz kurz zur Erinnerung, damit wir alle auf dem gleichen Stand sind.
Was sind Passkeys überhaupt?
Wir haben darüber ja schon mehrere Videos gemacht.
Die verlinken wir euch natürlich in der Beschreibung.
Passkeys ersetzen Passwörter.
Und was ihr euch auf jeden Fall merken könnt, Passkeys sind vom Sicherheitsstandpunkt her definitiv besser als Passwörter.
Warum? Weil euer privater Schlüssel immer auf eurem Gerät bleibt.
Nur der Öffentliche geht an den Dienst, bei dem ihr euch anmelden wollt.
Das heißt also, auch wenn der Dienst gehackt wird, braucht ihr euch keine Gedanken zu machen, dass eure Accounts gekapert werden.
Und noch ganz wichtig, Parskis sind prinzipbedingt gegen Phishing geschützt.
Also die funktionieren nur auf der Website, auf der ihr euch anmelden wollt.
Also auf YouTube.com.
Aber wenn man sich irgendein Rootkit oder sonst was einfängt, ist natürlich auch kacke, ne?
Da sind Dinge auch weg.
Und eben nicht auf YouTube.com oder so.
Und ganz klar ein Riesenvorteil, ihr müsst euch keine Passwörter mehr merken.
Ihr könnt euch einfach mit Fingerabdruck oder Gesichtserkennung anmelden.
Also eigentlich alles ganz nice, aber es gibt halt auch Probleme.
Die großen Tech-Konzerne nutzen Passkeys nämlich gerne, um euch an ihre Plattform zu binden.
Ein Passkey auf...
Wer hätte das gedacht, ne?
Das versuchen die ja sonst nie.
Auf dem iPhone bringt euch auf dem Windows-Rechner herzlich wenig, außer ihr scannt halt...
Übrigens, ey, Leute,
ich soll nochmal sidetracken.
Ich wollte mich letztens bei meinem Xbox-Account
einloggen.
Hab mich versucht, in meinen Xbox-Account einzuloggen.
Und dann kam das.
Ich soll ein Passkey
kreieren mit Windows.
Da hab ich gesagt, was? Moment, Moment.
Ich hab kein Passkey, ich will kein Passkey createn.
Ich will mich einfach nur einloggen in meinen Xbox-Account.
Dann hab ich das probiert,
hab auch weitergeklickt und dann kam das.
Wie konnten Create a Passkey?
Wie auch, ja?
Also so ein Schwachsinn, Alter.
Die können mich mal am Arsch lecken, Alter.
Also Opt-in ist das ja okay.
Aber für...
Du musst jetzt, dass du dich überhaupt wieder einloggen kannst.
Wie bist du dann reingekommen?
Ja, das ist ja das Beste.
Das ist ja das Beste.
Ich habe dann einen anonymen Tab im Browser aufgemacht und habe mich da versucht einzuloggen.
Und dann konnte ich ganz normal mit zwei Faktor-Authentifizierungs-App mich einloggen.
Frag nicht, Microsoft, ja?
Keine Ahnung.
...an, wie wir das selbst in die Hand nehmen können.
Beide Möglichkeiten bieten natürlich nicht nur Passkey-Unterstützung, sondern auch ganz klassisch Passwörter an.
Möglichkeit 1, ihr hostet auf eurem Homeserver Voltwarden.
Okay, ich bin ja froh, dass der genauso Probleme hat, das auszusprechen wie ich.
Voltwarden.
Das ist eine Open-Source-Lösung, die eure Passwörter und eben auch Passkeys abspeichert
und mit den ganz normalen Bitwarden-Apps funktioniert.
Voltwarden, Voltwarden, Voltwarden.
Ich kann das gerade auch nicht aus.
Volt, Volt, oder? Voltwarden.
Ich krieg's auch nicht gewackt, gell?
Die gibt es ja für die meisten Browser und auf Android und iOS.
Vault Warden könnt ihr einfach als Docker-Container auf eurem Home-Server installieren.
Hier als Beispiel habe ich das in KasaOS gemacht.
Da kriegt ihr das direkt aus dem KasaOS App Store.
Einfach installieren klicken.
Aber auch bei anderen Home-Server-Systemen könnt ihr das einfach als Docker-Container
installieren.
Achtung, hier kommt direkt Hürde Nummer 1, SSL-Zertifikate.
Wichtig für Vault-Warden, ihr müsst zwingend ein SSL-Zertifikat hinterlegen, sonst funktioniert das mit den Pass-Keys nicht.
Der Browser sagt sonst einfach Nö.
Denn die Browser hantieren wirklich nur mit Pass-Keys rum, wenn ihr in einem sogenannten Secure-Context seid.
Und das ist eben HTTPS und dafür braucht man ein SSL-Zertifikat.
Um das zu kriegen, gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten.
Wir haben da ziemlich lange drüber diskutiert, was denn jetzt der beste Sweetspot zwischen einfach zu installieren und okaye Sicherheit ist.
Und wir haben uns für Cloudflare empfohlen.
Ach, jetzt mal eine Frage.
Irgendjemand hat doch gesagt, gerade im Chat, er benutzt OTP-Auth oder irgendwie sowas, gell?
Wie funsten das da mit dem Sync?
Du hast doch gesagt, du hast das auf
Irgendwie lokale
Cloud-Sache, wo du das mit einem
Pfeil züngst
Muss man dazu die App öffnen?
Regelmäßig, oder wie ist das?
Bei den Background-Züngen
Wird es ja wahrscheinlich nicht können auf iOS
Es war ein kommerzieller Anbieter, der auch in den USA ist.
Ist uns klar nicht die allersauberste Lösung, aber es ist eben in diesem Fall die einfachste Lösung.
Wenn ihr das nicht wollt, sage ich aber gleich auch noch was dazu.
Gibt es natürlich noch tausend Alternativen.
Um Cloudflare zu nutzen, braucht ihr nur einen kostenlosen Account und könnt dann hier unter dem Punkt Zero Trust einen neuen Tunnel anlegen.
Wichtig, Cloudflare erstellt euch einen Tunnel ins Heimnetz, das heißt der Traffic wird dann auch über Cloudflare geroutet.
Es gibt aber auch noch ganz viele andere Möglichkeiten, zum Beispiel Pangolin war zumindest in Zeit mal sehr angesagt.
Das würde hier wirklich in diesem Video zu weit gehen, aber wenn ihr da Interesse dran habt, dann guckt euch das doch mal genauer an.
So, aber jetzt wieder zurück zu Cloudflare.
Wenn ihr das damit machen wollt, kopiert ihr diesen Befehl, der mit Docker run anfängt, in euer Terminal auf eurem Homeserver.
Und warum überhaupt genau?
Sucker Punch, danke schön für den Sub.
Warum jetzt genau braucht man das überhaupt, dass man von überall drankommt für seinen Sync oder wie?
Samus Climber!
Kasa OS
Simple, easy to use, elegant, open source, personal cloud system.
Ach, das sind diese Typen, die auch SEMA Board oder sowas da verkaufen.
Okay, sechs Monate Updates.
Das ist schon ein bisschen länger her.
Ach, das gibt es nicht mehr, oder was?
Ach, ist jetzt
SEMA OS.
SEMA OS
GitHub.
Ah, das ist jetzt das Neue.
Simplified
Focused and Open NAS
OS.
Aha.
Next Generation. Ah, das ist jetzt ein
NAS OS.
nicht so sicher ob man das wirklich braucht
aber was wir machen können ist können das mal schnell in der vm reinhauen und
mal installieren also nachdem wir das video fertig geguckt haben installer iso
und das video noch fertig
die cloudflare anwendung einfach auf der grafischen nutzeroberfläche und dann gebt
ihr da euren token ein aus eurem cloudflare account kurz danach läuft das als container
bei euch im Hintergrund und die Anzeige hier
im Cloudflare Dashboard sollte auf
Healthy, also grün, umschalten.
Unter dem Punkt Public Hostname
wählt ihr dann eine Subdomain, in dem Fall
nennen wir sie mal Vault.
Wenn ihr eine Domain bei Cloudflare habt...
Mich interessiert eher, was da am Ende bei rauskommt.
Nummer 2, KeePassXC.
KeePass, beste, Leute.
Benutze ich seit Jahrzehnten.
Ist jetzt nicht mal übertrieben, ne?
Wirklich seit Jahrzehnten.
Nicht als KeePassXC,
Das gibt es noch nicht so lange, aber KeyPass an sich, schon ewig benutze ich das.
Beste.
Lokal und Datei.
Und wenn ihr wirklich so richtig lokal mit euren Passkeys sein wollt,
also auf Wunsch sogar komplett ohne Netzwerk, dann schaut euch mal KeyPass XC an.
Ich sage ehrlich, das ist optisch jetzt nicht die allergrößte Urplatte.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber dafür macht es eben auch genau das, was es soll.
Das Gute ist, für KeyPass gibt es für alle Plattformen Apps und ihr bekommt die Passkeys auch als Datei,
die ihr einfach auf einem USB-Stick zum Beispiel backuppen könnt.
Zusätzlich könnt ihr die Keypass-Dateien...
Ich wusste auch nicht, dass es das kann, aber anscheinend.
No.
Anscheinend schon.
Dann müsste ich jetzt eine neue Database
createn.
Ah, mach ich jetzt nicht, aber
cool.
Wie synchronisierst
du deinen Keypass mit anderen Geräten?
Gar nicht.
Das bleibt schön bei mir auf dem Rechner und wird nicht in der Welt verteilt, mein Keypass.
Gar nicht. Das wird absichtlich nicht gesynct.
Das Einzige, wo es dabei ist, ist in einem Backup.
In einem Backup von meiner Kiste ist es mit dabei, falls die Kiste mal verreckt.
Das bleibt auf meinem Rechner. Da wird nichts gesynct.
Was machst du, wenn du Passwörter auf dem Handy brauchst?
Ganz ehrlich, ich tippe die Passwörter ab.
wie oft braucht man ein passwort ich brauche beim neu einrichten der app
brauche ich ein passwort und ansonsten sehr selten
ich brauche das sehr selten wie oft wie oft gibt ihr passwörter ein auf märz
hälschen grenzen ja
die zwei faktor codes brauchst du auf einem zweiten gerät die passwörter aber
nicht ich brauche die nicht auf dem zweiten gerät unbedingt die zwei faktor authentifizierung scott
ich brauche die aber noch woanders als nur auf einem gerät weil ich nicht will dass wenn mein
handy wenn wir am frankfurt hauptbahnhof eines handy cloud ich mich nicht mehr einloggen kann
gut ganz ehrlich ich generiere kein random passwort mit 128 zeichen
das mache ich nicht
nicht mal mein WLAN Passwort hat 128
Zeichen, ich weiß gar nicht ob WPA das überhaupt kann
mein WLAN Passwort hat
64 Zeichen, das reicht
ja
und das WLAN Passwort kann ich glücklicherweise
auch mit einem QR Code
an neue Geräte verteilen, das muss ich nicht abtippen
aber Passwörter sagen wir mal
für, ok Moment
was nehmen wir mal, irgendeine App
irgendeine App mit einem Passwort
Dann habe ich ein ganz normales, keine Ahnung, 20-stelliges, 22-stelliges, was auch immer Passwort mit Zahlen und Wörtern drin. Das kann man ganz gut tippen.
die zweite Alternative wäre
tatsächlich eine
zweite Passwort
safe, kann ja auch ein zweiter
Keypass safe sein
und
den könnte man synken, aber brauche ich nicht
kennst du die aus, wenn ich, ne, wenn du gerade mal
brauchst, wenn du nicht zu Hause bist, ich brauche keine Passwörter
wenn ich nicht zu Hause bin
und wenn, dann warte ich, bis ich daheim bin
ich hab ja alle Apps auf dem Handy
drauf und die sind eingerichtet, die brauchen dann in der Regel
auch kein Passwort mehr
Deutschland Ticket App
da hast du recht
da hast du recht, das stimmt
für die
Ticket-App habe ich tatsächlich, das ist eines
der wenigen Sachen, wo ich das Passwort öfters
brauche. Das Passwort habe ich einfach lokal
auf dem Handy gespeichert in der
ganz normalen iOS
Passwortmanager.
Aber die wird auch
nicht gesynct, die ist nur lokal auf dem Handy drauf.
Ja, das könnte man machen,
aber wie gesagt, ich will meine Keypass-Datei
gar nicht großartig verteilen.
Also da habe ich
wenige Apps, die das wollen.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist Absicht.
Ich will meine Keypass-Datei nicht verteilen.
Es ist aber auch das Ding,
wenn du, wenn du,
achso, du hast drei Datenbanken
mit Passwörter, 2FA und Passkeys.
Das ist natürlich sinnvoll.
Ja, da hast du das zumindest schon mal
schön getrennt und kannst entscheiden,
was du wie wohin singst.
Ding ist aber auch,
wenn du alles im gleichen Programm hast
oder nebeneinander liegen hast, wenn sich jemand Zugang zu deinem Rechner irgendwie verschafft,
ich rede jetzt nicht davon, dass einer einbricht bei dir oder so,
sondern dass du dir irgendwelche Malware einfängst,
dann hast du halt im Zweifelsfall zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung und Passwörter in den falschen Händen.
Aber es ist immerhin schon mal deutlich safer als irgendwelche TXT-Files.
ja, du musst ja dann immer noch
abgucken,
musst ja dann immer noch jemanden mitschneiden, wenn du
gerade dieses Programm geöffnet hast, dann irgendwas
aus dem RAM abgreifen oder
dein Passwort mitloggen,
das dann im Hintergrund irgendwie entsperren, das ist natürlich
deutlich aufwendiger, ja, also das ist nochmal deutlich
sicherer als TXT-File rumliegen zu haben.
Doch, es gibt eine KeePass-App
im App Store, relativ sicher, habe ich letztens erst
geguckt.
Ja, One Password sind bei mir unten durch.
Generell, alle Cloud-Anbieter-Passworten würde ich im Leben nicht verwenden.
Das Höchste der Gefühle, was bei mir in die Tüte kommen würde, ist,
ein eigener Keypass-Store,
den ich selbst
bei einem Cloud-Anbieter meiner Wahl
verschlüsselt hochlade.
Man könnte ja sagen, der Keypass ist schon verschlüsselt, ja.
Ich würde es aber tatsächlich nochmal encrypten,
davor mit irgendeinem transparenten Encryption-Layer,
so EncFS oder sowas,
und dann auf das Cloud-Laufwerk legen.
Das würde ich mir gefallen lassen.
Im Höchsten der Gefühle.
und dann aber auch nur für ausgewählte Passwörter, die ich synchen muss und nicht einfach stumpf meinen kompletten Passwort save.
So, jetzt gucken wir das Video fertig.
Natürlich auch direkt über die Cloud automatisch zwischen euren Geräten synchron halten.
Das geht dann entweder über große Hersteller-Clouds wie iCloud, Google Drive oder Dropbox.
Aber da kommt ihr natürlich vom Regen in die Traufe, denn genau das wollten wir ja vermeiden, dass die Dateien bei den großen Herstellern gehostet werden.
Aber ihr könnt natürlich auch euren eigenen Cloud-Dateispeicher verwenden, wie zum Beispiel Nextcloud auf eurem Home-Server.
Um Pass-Keys bei KeyPass XC zu verwenden, braucht ihr mindestens...
O-Ton habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Wenn ihr das Ding zum ersten Mal startet, legt ihr eine neue Datenbank an, ihr wählt ein Master-Passwort.
Das sollte so lang sein, dass ihr es euch gerade noch merken könnt.
schreibt es euch sicherheitshalber
auf den Zettel und packt das dann an.
Das kann ich, ja, da muss ich eben echt
mal beipflichten.
Bei vielen Leuten
ist im Kopf drin, das Schlimmste,
was man machen kann, ist
einen Zettel mit einem Passwort drauf zu haben.
Das stimmt aber überhaupt nicht.
Und ich rede jetzt nicht von,
dass Login-Passwort für den Arbeitsrechner
sich mit einem Post-it an Monitor hängen.
Ja, aber selbst
das, ganz ehrlich, selbst
Das ist nicht so schlimm, wie es auf den ersten Blick aussieht, weil die brauchen ja immer physisch Zugang zu deinem Arbeitsplatz. Ja, aber das würde ich nicht unbedingt machen. Aber daheim ist das gar nicht verkehrt. Wie gesagt, ich habe auch einen Zettel mit OTPs, falls ich mal meine Zwei-Faktor-Identifizierung verlieren sollte.
Bei mir habe ich den ausgedruckten Zettel liegen, denn Passwörter auf dem Papier haben einen großen Vorteil versus Passwortsaves oder andere elektronischen Sachen. Man hat da halt so einen Medienbruch dazwischen. Selbst wenn irgendjemand bei euch das heftigste Rootkit installiert hat und alles auf eurem Rechner machen kann als Root, dann kann der immer noch nicht in euren Schrank gucken und die Passwörter auf dem Zettel lesen.
Es sei denn, ihr habt diese komische neue Drohne von Xiaomi?
Ich weiß gar nicht, es gab doch letztens so eine Drohne für daheim,
die in der Wohnung rumfliegen kann und Sachen filmen.
Ja, also wenn ihr so eine Drohne habt und die vom Rechner steuerbar ist,
ey, die kann aber immer noch nicht die Schranktür aufmachen, ja?
Aber ihr habt da halt so einen Medienbruch dazwischen.
Das heißt, jemand, der bei euch den Rechner komplett übernommen hat,
kann nicht auf den Zettel gucken.
Das heißt, auf dem Schreibtisch einen Zettel liegen zu haben,
mit Passwörtern für Notfall
und so oder für
das Passwort für den Keysave
oder so, das ist gar nicht
so doof.
Das ist gar nicht so blöd.
Kann er die Printerlogs auslesen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob in Printerlogs die
Printerjobs nochmal im Klartext drin stehen.
Keine Ahnung.
Theoretisch gibt es sicherlich, es gibt immer
irgendwelche Möglichkeiten. Aber das ist
deutlich sicherer, als man so denkt.
Ja, also das ist gar nicht so blöd.
Einen sicheren Ort, weil das ist ja nur wirklich euer absolutes Masterpasswort.
Das wäre blöd, wenn ihr das vergesst.
Am besten in einen unsprengbaren Tresor.
Ja, und dann speichert ihr die Datenbank.
Also ich habe glaube ich schon acht, muss ich mal kurz über 10, 48 stelle ich das Passwort.
Das ist glaube ich für meinen Masterkey.
Warte mal.
Moment, ich kann gerade nicht zählen.
Ja.
48-stelliges Passwort.
Es ist tatsächlich reiner Zufall, dass es 48 Stellen ist. Also das hat nichts mit IT 2 hoch irgendwas zu tun, sondern, ne 2 hoch irgendwas passt gar nicht. Das ist tatsächlich Zufall, dass es 48 Stellen hat.
Achso, du meinst 12345678, ja das Beste, das würde ich auch immer, immer das Best Practice Passwort. 123456, das haben so viele und wenn so viele Leute so ein Passwort benutzen, kann das nicht schlecht sein.
auf eurem Rechner. Ich habe die Dateien in einem Ort, an der sich automatisch mit meiner Nextcloud
synchron hält. Dann habe ich die direkt auch auf meinen anderen Geräten. Damit der Browser jetzt
mit KeePassXC reden kann, braucht ihr noch die Erweiterung KeePassXC Browser. In KeePassXC selbst
klickt ihr oben auf das Zahnrad, dann auf Browser Integration und setzt den Haken bei Browser
Integration aktivieren. Ja, aber ich nicht. Dann spielt euren Browser aus der Liste aus und jetzt
im Browser auf das KeyPass-Icon klicken und verbinden.
Gebt der Verbindung einen Namen und wichtig, geht in der Browser-Erweiterung nochmal in die Einstellung,
scrollt runter bis Passkeys und setzt da unbedingt das Häkchen bei Passkeys aktivieren.
Sonst wundert ihr euch, warum nichts passiert.
Ja, probieren wir es mal aus.
Ich gehe auf eine Testseite wie webauthen.io, trage einen Nutzernamen ein,
klicke auf Register und seht ihr das?
KeyPass XC meldet sich sofort.
Willst du ein Passkey erstellen? Ja, will ich.
Bestätigen. Beim Login genau das gleiche.
authenticate klicken, KeyPass.
Welches Video ist das? CT3003?
Das letzte.
Von denen.
Ich bestätige und ich bin drin.
Und das Beste, wenn ihr in KeyPass
XC auf Datenbank und Parskeys geht,
dann habt ihr direkt so eine Übersicht.
Ihr könnt Parskeys sogar exportieren.
Aber Vorsicht, wenn ihr die exportiert,
liegen die
privaten Schlüssel im
Klartext vor. Also ist ganz cool,
wie so ein Passkey aussieht. So, ne?
So, so. Aber macht das wirklich
nur, wenn ihr wisst, was ihr tut.
Wenn ihr die Keypass-Datei auch noch auf anderen...
Gibt es irgendjemand, der wirklich von sich behaupten kann,
er weiß, was er tut? Ich weiß nicht,
was ich tue. ...Geräte verwenden wollt, dann könnt
ihr die, wie gesagt, über die Cloud...
Ich tue nur so. ...oder ihr übertragt die manuell
per Kabel oder AirDrop.
Für zusätzliche Sicherheit könnt ihr auch noch
eine Schlüsseldatei erzeugen. Die braucht
ihr dann auch auf allen Geräten, aber kopiert
die eben per kabel und legt die nicht in die cloud ja und dann ladet ihr euch noch die entsprechende
app auf euer smartphone oder tablet mittlerweile gibt es auch apps für android und ios die die
kippas passkies unterstützen auf ios sind da kipas yum und strongbox auf android wäre da kippas dx
cx und strongbox ganz gut auf ok android wäre da kippas dx cx dx ist ein bisschen verwirrend naja
Die Apps sind relativ ähnlich aufgebaut. Ihr wählt eure Datenbank aus, euren Dateien, gebt euer Passwort ein und gegebenenfalls die Schlüsseldatei.
Bei iOS wählt ihr die App dann in den Einstellungen noch unter Automatisch ausfüllen und passt sie auf.
Sachsen-Silber, danke für den Sub.
Pog, Subscription.
128-stärkiges Passwort mit Curve 25519 verschlüsselt und das alles mit einer Diskette transportiert. Beste.
Elliptic Curve.
Das gleiche unter Passwörter, Passkeys und Konten.
Also ich finde Passkeys nach wie vor super und verwende die wo immer es geht.
In der Praxis habe ich die schon alleine aus Testgründen auf mehreren Geräten und mehreren
Accounts und es ist auch wirklich sinnvoll da nicht nur bei einem Anbieter mit zu sein.
Also bei so wichtigen Accounts wo es weh tut nicht mehr reinzukommen,
erstelle ich einfach gleich mehrere Passkeys.
Ja wie sieht es bei euch aus? Traut ihr euch dran an Voltworden oder Keypass oder bleibt
ihr lieber bei den komfort lösungen wie apple und google oder haltet ihr passt
ist generell für teufelszeug und arbeitet weiter ist der pass zu enter
to ask er eine gute argumente in die kommentare schreiben wenn euch das video
geholfen hat okay jetzt haben wir hier schon am start
leute jetzt müssen wir das mal das interessiert mich jetzt einfach okay
chat ich lasse euch das ich lasse euch das
Ihr könnt euch das aussuchen.
Entweder gucken wir uns noch die restlichen Videos fertig.
Also da gibt es ja nicht mehr so viele.
Noch 1, 2 oder so.
Oder wir gucken uns mal kurz Zima OS an.
Irgendwie interessiert mich das.
Leg schon mal eine VM an.
Ich will das einfach nur mal installieren und ein bisschen drin rumklicken.
Nichts Großartiges, sage ich gleich.
Also 20, 30 Minuten oder so.
Höchstens.
face reveal bin ich ja bekannt für zu face revealen
warum benutzt ihr die pxe bootkiste
os image download sima os zack cd
als nicht connected ist natürlich dumm cd drive
ach so
auch vor allem wer sehr schlimm kann es sein dass die zimmer os so irgendwie
nicht gut was soll das können wir das will ich ja gerade nachgucken
ich will nicht px e booten ich will von der iso booten von dem von der cd booten
das geht nicht was ist denn das dass er die erste
iso die man booten kann oder ist es eine feierwehr geschichte
hast du und ja ich habe euch weiter gemacht hier guck mal da und download war doch auch
erfolgreich oder ja
ist vor allem nicht arschteuer das geht nicht man kann die sie so nicht
Okay, okay.
Vmware ist kostenlos mittlerweile.
Vmware Workstation.
Ich lege das hier gerade nochmal zusammen.
So, mal gucken, ob sie jetzt funzt.
Ach, nervt mich rum vor MW, Alter.
Das geht nicht, das ISO ist kaputt.
Das ISO ist kaputt.
Das bootet nicht.
Ah, Moment, man muss auf EFI umschalten.
Kann das sein?
Da stand doch irgendwas von EFI only.
Das wird's sein.
Da stand doch irgendwas.
EFI boot only.
Ah, okay.
welcome install jawohl darauf last chance yes
schon mal ein easy installer das gefällt mir das ist ein speaker sounds auch so ein guter guter
Punkt, was ich
customised habe. Ich habe bei den meisten
Images, die ich von mir über PXE booten kann,
habe ich PC Speaker
Blacklist, dass PC Speaker nicht
geladen wird, das Modul.
Max, was hast du für einen Aufbau?
Windows 11 rechnen mit VMS drauf.
Ja. Und bald noch
einen Linux Mini PC.
Der steht schon hier.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich deine Mutter
selbst sie muss installieren will minis forum ist kein minis form ist ein
beelink beelink es er 7 mit einem 8 core reisen
bootings lott ok
Ich hab 64 Gramm, aber zu Zeiten, wo es noch billiger war.
Und lädt das jetzt?
Oder was, was, äh...
Macht das jetzt?
Macht das irgendwas?
Hallo, Chat.
mittlerweile war es mein ball also die die neue version die ist so dermaßen schlecht
mittlerweile weiß man gar nicht ist es verpackt der müll von dem was du
installiert hast oder es ist verpackt der müll von vm aber ob es nicht geht
und jetzt
und jetzt macht das jetzt irgendwas oder
puzzle meister
ist jetzt brauchen oder was
was ist denn hier?
Okay, ich reboote nochmal.
Das ist kaputt.
Oder braucht es einfach
super lange,
bis es bootet.
jetzt stellen das ding mal um stellen das ding immer auf prüft um aller
fälle man die soundkarte raus
halt noch aus
Macht nix
Soll ich mal in meinen Router gucken
Ob das nicht vielleicht schon
Gebooted ist
Dieses
Ne
Nee, nee, ist es nicht.
Also Leute, das mit CimaOS
angucken wir nix, weil das bootet nicht.
Funktioniert nicht.
Hat das eine IP?
Nö.
Ich habe gerade im Router geguckt.
Das macht nichts.
Unter Virtualbox klappt es.
Ja, vielleicht ist es auch ein VMware-Ding.
Keine Ahnung.
Mittlerweile weiß es ja nicht.
Warte mal.
Slot A, Slot B?
Was soll das?
Ah, non-falsch.
Geil.
Slot A, Rescue Shell.
Seht ihr da was?
Virtual Box.
Ey, das ist doch komplett kaputt alles, oder?
Nehmen wir mal die Rescue-Schicht.
Der hat nicht richtig installiert.
Der hat irgendwie rumgebugt beim Installen.
So.
Wir booten jetzt nochmal von der CD.
Install.
Wir machen das jetzt nochmal.
Habe ich irgendwas verkehrt gemacht?
Install.
Da drauf. Yes. Yes.
Ich hab das Gefühl, es installiert jetzt länger als das letzte Mal.
Oder?
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Do me now reboot.
die musste ja
die maus vor einem skirt in stahl
Muss ich dort jetzt vielleicht...
Vor allem bei 3D-Acceleration...
Was?
Install ISO geht nicht? Was zum...
hat mich verarschen
das ist anscheinend high iq man kann nicht einfach das installer verwenden
Okay, I just tried it again, but this time I used custom advanced options and changed
the 4MR hardware compatibility from 4MR to 17 or later.
This made all different...
Was?
Ernsthaft?
Seriously?
Wirklich?
Ernsthaft? Seriously?
Okay.
Das kann ich mir gerade vorstellen.
Custom. Hardware-Complete.
17 Uhr später.
Linux.
5 eine cpu 5 kurs 16 gig meinetwegen in der us-network-projekte create new disc
store komplex halt 64 pc speaker noch aus
denk an efi du hast recht advanced den shit aus efi an
mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert also wenn es das das hatte ich ja auch noch nie dass die
vmware hardware version ernsthaft irgendwas damit zu tun hat weil dir das geht jetzt ich
glaub's ja nicht einfach ein hardware version what the fuck muss man
anscheinend machen
jetzt war es gerade wieder uefi ja muss es ja auch sein ohne uefi bote das nicht
Ja, also vor allem der Workstation ist richtig mies geworden mit der 25er Version.
Keine Ahnung, was die da treiben.
Okay, so, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Ja.
Nein.
ok da habe ich schon wieder kein bock das auszuprobieren
sata was zum
ok ok ok ja ja ok da macht es mit workstation 17 wahrscheinlich auch eine bessere idee
Ja, ja, mach mal ein bisschen.
Zata!
Alter, was ist das für ein Schrott?
Das kann ich mir aber nicht vorstellen, dass das was bringt.
Also einmal probiere ich es noch.
Einmal probiere ich es noch.
Ich weiß, man kann es einfach umstellen,
aber ich mache das jetzt nochmal mit dem Assistent, okay?
new virtual machine kasse und 7 17.5 later iso avalinux jawohl ja ich nehme auch mal vier wie
der hatte 16 gig bridge network sata
ganz so nett sein das glaube ich nicht dass das das ist das glaube ich nicht
dass es das ist
das glaube ich es wird jetzt auch nicht funktionieren
oh ne ne ne ah shit shit shit ja ja ja ich hab vergessen umzustellen ist ja gut
weil er ist gut ist gut uefi uefi stellt habe ich ver...
das wird's das wird's jetzt auch nicht klappen das glaub ich nicht
ich muss meine hausarbeit am ende dieses tages abgeben zeit hat sich zeit sich
hier mal zur Mitte. Ja, für GLHF.
Also wenn das jetzt funzt mit SATA,
dann, also egal wie das ausgeht,
Ne? Wenn es jetzt
funzt,
ist es Schrott.
Und wenn es nicht funzt, ist es auch Schrott.
Das ist
egal, wie man es nimmt. Es ist immer Schrott.
Gibt es das eigentlich auch für Raspberry Pi?
Und wenn es
halb funzt, ist es auch Schrott.
Also ohne Mist, so viel Probleme
wie mit VMware 25
hatte ich mit keiner anderen Version
bisher und ich benutze das auch schon Jahrzehnte.
Seit Version 4.5 oder sowas.
Es geht! Seriously!
Satan! Oh meine
Fresse, Alter! Das kann doch jetzt
nicht sein!
Ist Twitch deine Haupteinnahmequelle?
Quatsch, ich verdiene mit Twitch so gut wie gar nichts.
sata muss die ich weiß gar nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
etf
in ebischut logging auf ssh nee so reicht mir also okay wir müssen jetzt auf 17 12 14 7 beim
zimmer os welcome to accept privacy war muss in der policy exzellenz was way to minute
naja komplett mich egal great local account max 123456 super high passwort so was will
ist jetzt von mir. Combine hard
managed assets and data.
Was?
Start from files?
Start from App Store.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht, was die von mir wollen.
Wir gehen zum Dashboard.
Nein, ich will kein Client.
Okay, das Interface gefällt mir nicht.
Das merke ich jetzt.
Wisst ihr, es ist bei mir ganz merkwürdig.
Ich habe so, der erste Eindruck von der Software ist bei mir immer entscheidend.
Wenn ich so jetzt schon was sehe und denke, äh.
Egal, aber wir lassen uns jetzt da nicht zu sehr davon ablenken.
Gucken wir mal.
Was ich mache, ich habe gerade CimaOS installiert und gucke mir das an.
Bin aber nicht so wirklich begeistert.
So Widget Settings.
Und gibt es erstmal
Okay, whatever
Also platte haben wir hier am start
network system remote access remote access prominent file management von den new drive
Ein cd laufwerk view and migrate
Okay, das ist quasi ein File Explorer im Browser.
Wir haben da ein Wake-up-and-Learn-Tool im...
Okay, Moment. Das gucken wir jetzt.
Wo ist denn der App Store überhaupt?
Äh, App Store.
Der App Store sieht verdächtig nach Apple App Store aus.
Vom Icon her.
Finde ich. Auch von dem blauen her.
ZVM?
Ist das?
Ah, man kann
VMs laufen lassen. Naja, gut.
Debian.
Fail to Dawn
geht schon gut los.
Ähm, App Store.
Wie, wie?
UpSnap.
Tatsächlich.
Da ist er.
das ist null mb placing die fast jetzt das web interface lässt sich auch eklig
bedienen ok keine ahnung was wo es kann von zwei faktor authentifizierung haben
machen wir das doch jetzt einfach mal hier zwei faktoren install letztendlich
startet es unter der haube docker container gehe ich zumindest mal von aus
installation completed
ich weiß nicht gucken wir mal ob es ente orth gibt ente
gibt es natürlich nicht ganz ehrlich dann nehme ich lieber dann nehme ich
lieber doch pläne und mach mein eigenes das installieren hängt geil weil nämlich
lieber doch pläne und mach mein eigenes und ausfall das installieren hängt es
geht schon nicht
Geil
Ah, jetzt geht's
Boah, Alter, wie lange hat das gebraucht?
Was starten die da unter der Haube?
Kann man sich jetzt streiten, ob es geht?
Ne, das ist einfach Timeout
Und es geht immer noch nicht
Geil
Ich weiß nicht.
Wir gehen jetzt da mal per SSH drauf.
Äh.
Chat.
Könnt ihr euch da jetzt beim Internet von einloggen, oder was?
Wenn ihr die ID habt.
Please keep it confidential.
Okay.
Und tschüss.
Seid ihr schon drin, Chat?
In der ausgeschalteten VM.
was mag ich nicht und tschüss zimmer os abgehakt werde ich nicht verraten
mail to load ja ich hab's ja abgeschaltet
muss nicht sein das ist was war das für ein video hier ach so der auto install
ok da haben wir das doch relativ schnell abgehakt oder mit zimmer os
und die folgt an auch kritisch die folgen an und die login geschichte
direkt im plaintext angezeigt oder icon ja ja also das finde ich auch nicht gut
was waren die highlights von zimmer os dass ich jeder im internet raus einloggen kann
deswegen habe ich wieder ausgeschaltet und an installt
also jeder mit der mit der not mit der id aber die id steht halt im plaintext da
Kann man nicht einfach den Port sperren?
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Für mich sah das so aus,
als ist da irgendein
so Nut-Pinhole-mäßig
über den
ihren Server mit dabei, wenn du die ID hast.
Was genau macht das,
dass man sich ohne Port freigabt?
Ja, ich gehe davon aus,
also meine Vermutung ist,
das verbindet sich zu zimmer us server und dort quasi kommt es beide seiten
verbinden sich zum team server und
darüber kommunizieren die quasi welcher port offen ist also kannst ja das ist
so ein pin holen wie heißt das glaube ich nicht pin holen also gehst du gehst
zu einem externen server über den port und teilst du mit welcher welcher port
das ist und dann kann andere sich dahin connecten irgendwie so so nach pinhole
heißt das irgendwie nicht nach pinhole nutt genau
was das meine ich nicht firewall pinhole das mal
ja ach fragt mich nicht genau wie es sonst
also dass das rate ich jetzt dass das so ist ja
also dass es standardmäßig alles und das installieren von der ersten app hat
auch schon richtig funktioniert kam es brauche ich nicht und man davon abgesehen
dass lässt der elends unter der haube nun container laufen das kann ich auch
mit einem eigenen docker file compose file oder image direkt angeben
und ein bisschen komplizierter zu haus eine sache wie ente auch
gar nicht im store also das brauchen wir nicht
tunas hat auch so was aber auch bei default an welches las hast du ich hab mir ich habe
zwei mittlerweile stimmt nicht ganz noch habe ich nicht zwei ich habe mir jetzt hier zum testen das
da gekauft.
Kostet bei Amazon
aber nur 599.
Mit 8 Gigramm.
Achso, mit den Containern.
Joa.
So. Aber,
nachdem ich das gekauft habe
und es hier eingetroffen ist, es steht hier
neben mir, habe ich gesehen,
ähm,
dass es jetzt
die Pro-Variante gibt mit einem Performance-Core
mehr und den habe ich mir auch gleich mitbestellt.
Nochmal jetzt. Wird aber erst
am 11. Februar ausgeliefert. Ich warte jetzt,
bis ich beide da habe und dann gucke ich
mir das mal an.
Und eventuell
giveaway ich dann
das Plus im Stream,
weil ich brauche keine
zwei nasses...
Aber ohne RAM,
sage ich euch gleich, ohne RAM und SSDs.
willst du auf dem UK was anderes in szene lässt du das in einer nicht dass
you can us kommt hat sie direkt fliegt es runter wahrscheinlich box ja haben
die gpu ja ich glaube schon ja ja haben sie haben sie also bei den nassgeräten
passt es sind drei ssds passender rein unten hast du slots für zwei ssds aber intern hat das noch
128 gig nvme ssd noch eine dritte die kann man wenn man das gehäuse aufmacht kann man die auch
austauschen also man kann da drei ssds rein machen aber schön leicht dran zu kommen sind nur zwei ssd
Das andere ist eine interne.
Was aber gar nicht schlecht ist.
128 GB reicht für die OS-Installation.
Genau.
So.
Und für Nasszwecke reichen 8 GB auch dicke.
So ist das ja nicht.
Aber ich baue die 8 GB aus.
Aus dem neuen auch.
Stecke die in mein Mini-PC.
und bau dafür die 32 gb ein ich glaube die 8 gb ram naja dauer heißt ja ich nehme einfach
weg es geht darum er kriegt einfach nur weniger und den cfs nass selbst für den cfs nass reicht
das du hast natürlich ein problem wenn du jetzt sagst ich habe zehn gig netzwerk verbindung und
will da möglichst schnell drauf schreiben.
ZFS write cached ja alles
erstmal in RAM und dann so im
5 Sekunden Intervall
ähm, ja,
dafür ist das nix, aber
wir haben ja jetzt hier daheim keine Enterprise Business
Workloads. Da geht's auch
mit 8 Gig. Schön sind natürlich mehr,
ja, aber es
läuft auch mit 8 Gig.
ZFS läuft auch ohne ECC RAM
Sind wir hier im Freenas Forum oder was?
Ups, falscher
Im Freenas Forum
Da wurdest du früher auch angeflamed
Wie ZFS ohne
Ein Gig RAM pro Terabyte Speicher
Wie ZFS ohne ECC RAM
So als implodiert das
ZFS ist auch nicht schlechter
wie andere Filesysteme ohne ECC-RAM.
Sogar besser.
Die ganze Checksum-Geschichte macht es ja trotzdem zusätzlich.
Wenn man natürlich
RAM-Write-Cache
haben will,
mehr RAM schadet nicht.
Ich sage jetzt ja auch gar nicht, dass es schlecht ist.
Ich sage ja gar nicht, dass es schlecht ist.
Mehr RAM schadet auf jeden Fall nicht.
Und mit ECC ist sicherlich auch noch mal besser als ohne.
Aber das läuft auch ohne.
Gibt es das noch?
Administrator.de, Alter, da habe ich früher mal immer gelesen.
Im Forum.
Gibt es das immer noch?
Anscheinend.
Das Forum ist jetzt Web 2.0 und sieht hässlich aus, sodass man nichts mehr findet.
Geil, oder?
Jetzt mal ganz blöd.
warum denken die, dass solche Foren bessere Usability haben, als diese ganzen Oldschool-Foren?
So war es hier zum Beispiel.
Ich bin da nicht aktiv.
Hält mir nur gerade ein aus dem Kopf noch von früher.
Was war gegen solche?
Okay, das sieht Oldschool aus, ja.
Aber was war an solchen Foren denn schlecht?
Hier blickst du doch gar nicht mehr durch.
Hier ist das okay. Ah, ich interessiere mich für Technik.
Ah, okay, alle Threads. Gut.
Und kein Endless-Scroll, sondern einfach hier unten Pagination.
Und das da? Was ist das?
Weitere Beif... Boah, ist das schlecht, Alter.
The fuck?
erio offline connect von denen hatte ich früher mal hatten wir in der ganz ganz alten firma
sind firewall ding von cario beide scheiße das ist klar sich folgt ich bin ja auch ein ein fan von
Ich bin ja auch ein Fan von old.reddit.
Das ist mir auch viel lieber.
Das sieht halt einfach noch nach irgendwie einer Webseite aus.
Das hier findest du gar nichts, Alter.
windows 11 durch mint ersetzen okay der chat sagt das forum ist nervig wir
kontrollieren jetzt mal ob das forum nervig ist erster eindruck entscheidet
ich glaube linux ist nichts für dich sind immer die geilen kommentare dabei
naja geht doch noch aber das ist nichts gegen
das microcontroller forum einer das schlimmste forum
ever wenigsten sie das noch nach klassischen forum aus ja schön ist es nicht aber sie dem
stell dir mal fest wie wie schnell seht ihr wie schnell die webseite ist
wie schnell das ist
ok sp 32 wir suchen mal kurz was
Geht schon gleich gut los, Alter
Ich muss das gar nicht lesen, Mann
Das ist also ohne Scheiß, Mikrocontroller-Forum ist echt das Schlimmste.
Also das Arch-Lilungs-Forum kenne ich nicht.
Ich kenne nur das Arch-Wiki und das ist das Beste.
Nee, machen wir nicht.
Nun gut, was haben wir denn noch, was wir uns auf YouTube angucken können?
Ah, FireShip macht ja...
Stimmt, FireShip macht ja wieder nicht AI-Videos.
Gucken wir uns das doch bei der Gelegenheit auch gleich mal an.
Ten Open Source Tools That Feel Illegal.
Mal gucken, ob das was taugt.
mit hohen Risiken, die soziale Ingenieure ausüben, um persönliche Daten, intime Fotos und Kryptowaluten zu stehlen.
Aber dann gibt es Programmer.
Sie sind die unerhobenen Helden, die all das Software in der Welt machen, aber sie werden auch von Hackern penetriert.
Wenn ein Programmer die Rückseite des Haupts zu ihrem Hauptschutz lässt,
könnte es katastrophale Auswirkungen haben, die sie, ihren Job und ihren Mitarbeiter, Billionen von Dollar kosten.
Die Lektion, die hier gelernt wird, ist, dass du diejenige bist, der das Penetrieren macht,
nicht ein Außenstehender in einem anderen Land, der nicht einmal deine Gefühle interessiert.
In diesem Video lernt ihr die Grundlagen des ethischen Hackens und des Pentestings.
Schaut euch 10 kostenlose und open source-Tools an, die ihr jetzt nutzen könnt,
alle von denen sind per default auf Kali Linux verfügbar.
Der hat sich in der VM,
er hat sich Kali Linux
ISO runtergeladen,
hat Kali Linux
in der VM installiert und hat
dann Packages geupdatet.
Und das
ging über den Proxy
von der Firma, ja,
und da ist dann irgendwelches Security
Zeug angesprungen und da kamen
ganz panisch irgendwelche Leute ins Büro
geflitzt, dass hier
der Rechner irgendwie
unter Attacke stehe und ganz gefährliche Sachen damit passieren.
Und dann hat er gemeint, nee, ich hab, wie updatet man Kali-Packages?
Update gemacht.
Und dann haben sie sich riesen aufgeregt.
Wie kann das sein?
Hacker-Systeme werden hier installiert.
...
Kali kann man aber auch nie unethisch verwenden.
Ich glaube, das wäre auch schlecht.
Also, auf welcher Basis?
Ist ja nicht verboten.
Kali Linux in der VM, es macht ja auch überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass es verboten ist.
Ich wusste, ich wollte, ich habe extra Pause gemacht.
Ich wusste, dass jetzt ein Sponsoring kommt.
Der hat die Überleitung, hat er drauf.
Wie viele Icons habt ihr erkannt? Ich habe nicht richtig geguckt, ehrlich gesagt.
Oh, mal gucken, wie viele Icons wir erkennen.
Ähm, Aircrack?
Wireshark?
Äh
Ist das John the Ripper?
Halle Lilux?
Hashcat?
Metasploit
Okay, ja, stimmt, das hab ich schon mal gesehen
Sonst, keine Ahnung
Äh
Ist das Nmap? Was ist Nmap?
Was davon ist Nmap?
Ist das Nmap?
Ne, N...
Was hiervon ist Nmap?
Das Auge ist Nmap?
Ich wusste bis heute gar nicht, dass Nmap ein Logo hat.
Based Arch Linux User.
Jetzt kriegen wir erstmal eine Runde Sellout.
Meint ihr, Fireship war schon mal in einer Wüste?
in der haus mit auftragslehrer hat sich bei mir auf der alten arbeit auch mal
eine aufgeregt weil ich gucken wollte gar nicht mehr genau
also ich hab ich hab mein ip bereich da gescannt
da hat sich auch einer beschwert hier hacker tools am laufen
at work like the one you're connected to right now to watch this video
there's likely multiple host connected to it like your computer your playstation
in your smart lock and the purpose of n map is to map out a network it does
Sie sendet Pakete über eine IP-Range und analysiert ihre Antworten, um zu entscheiden, welche Ports offen sind, welche Operationssysteme sie nutzen, um zu helfen, Backdoors zu erzeugen.
Wie wenn mein Vater etwas auf seinem Netzwerk misskonfiguriert hat, kann man seinen Printer hacken, um ihm eine Botschaft zu senden.
Um sie zu nutzen, benutze ich einfach den Nmap-Kommand, folgenden von einem IP-Adress, den Sie haben, wie euren lokalen Netzwerk oder sogar eine URL, mit der Sie die Möglichkeit haben, sich zu penetrieren.
Wenn wir das auf einem Website machen, werden wir die IP-Adresse zurückfinden und es ist herausgefunden, dass die Ports 80 und 443 offen waren.
Das ist ziemlich cool, aber wir können auch eine mehr aggressive Scan mit der A-Option machen.
Dies wird nicht nur die Netzwerke scannen, sondern auch die funktionierenden Systeme detektieren.
Und wir werden etwas nennen Tracer-Route nutzen, um die Reise der Pakete über das gesamte Netzwerk zu tracken,
was helfen kann, Misskonfigurationen zu detektieren, die wir erzeugen können.
Wenn du Interesse an Paketen hast, ist es ein weiteres Tool, das du wissen musst.
Es ist wie der Typ an einer Party, der versucht, sich auf jede Gespräche zu verabschieden.
Es lässt dich überprüfen, was auf der Netzwerke passiert, auf einem mikroscopischen Niveau.
You'll want to use the GUI on this one, because it collects tons of data from hundreds of different protocols,
which are all captured in real time and can be analyzed offline.
For example, if you record the traffic on your network right now,
and notice all this weird traffic going to an IP address in North Korea,
you can inspect the actual payload and might find out that they have access to those photos
that were intended for only you and your future ex-wife to see.
And now you might be radicalized and ready to fight back.
Metasploit is perhaps the most powerful hacking framework out there.
Es ist wie ein Swiss Army Knife.
Attachung dazu, die die höchst unkröpfiche
Script-Kittys fördern, um einen Attakt anzusneten.
Zum Beispiel können wir die Möglichkeit haben,
eine Windows-Maschine mit einem deutschen Sch lobb
und die lokale HOST an unsere eigene IP-Adresse
konfigurieren. Und dann schlussendlich
die lobb-KommAND anruf.
Gratulation! Du hast eine erfolgreiche
penetration you can access all the files on this computer change the desktop
background and install even more malware but metasploit is almost too powerful
and if you use it you'll miss out on a lot of cyber security learning
opportunities the next tool you need to know about is air crack like the name
implies it's for hacking those magical invisible packets floating around in the
air called Wi-Fi when you're at Starbucks enjoying a soy latte coating a
node.js app there could be a guy behind the dumpster using air crack who just
ran the air mon command followed by air dump to find your network as the perfect
Er hat dann den Aircrack-Takt ausgerüstet, um den Wifi-verarmten Zugangsklick zu verändern und kann jetzt alle Pakete aus dünnem Luft fliegen lassen auf dieser Netzwerke.
Wenn du auf einer regelmäßigen ungeencrypten HTTP-Website verbunden bist, könnte deine sensiblen Daten verabschiedet werden.
Deshalb musst du immer HGTPS nutzen, wenn du Formen mit persönlichen Daten anbietest, weil auch wenn ein Hacker diese Pakete verabschiedet, werden sie verabschiedet.
Glücklicherweise hat der Polizist nur diesen Mann verhaftet, weil das Verhalten von Aircrack auf einer Netzwerke ohne Verabschiedung sehr illegal ist.
Aber jetzt ist es Zeit, um über Passwörter zu sprechen.
Normies, who watch Hollywood movies, think that hackers get access to the mainframe by running some program that cracks their password.
And believe it or not, Hollywood movies about hacking are 100% accurate.
Kali Linux has multiple password-cracking tools, like John the Ripper and Hydra, but the easiest tool to learn, in my opinion, is Hashcat.
First though, it's crucial to understand that nobody in their right mind stores a plain text.
Das ist irgendeine Castle-Folge, glaube ich.
Wenn ich das richtig im Hinterkopf habe.
Cyber-Nuke-Scene.
Ja, the most accurate hacking-scene ever.
Text password.
Ja.
Ja, MD5 ist ja mittlerweile komplett...
...ein Arsch.
Also für Security-Reasons, ja.
Also für...
Für andere Sachen kann man das verwenden,
Aber wenn es sicher sein soll, ist MD5 nicht so geil.
Ja, um Dateien miteinander zu vergleichen, kann man durchaus MD5 per...
Skipfish, hab ich noch nie gehört.
Cross-Site Scripting, SQL Injection und andere Web-Applikationen.
Es gibt einen guten HTML-Report.
Und was toll ist, ist, dass wenn du bereits ein Username und Passwort hackst,
kannst du diese Kredenzialien auch auf dem Deep Web verlassen,
außer dem, was dem Publikum vorhanden ist.
Dann, wenn du Verletzungen findest, kannst du Tools wie Cross-Site Scripter
installieren, wie mein Hero Sammy es in 2005 in MySpace gemacht hat.
Um ein erfolgreiches Cyberkriminal zu sein, musst du sich wie die Gefahr,
und ihre Tools wie Foremost, eine Forensische Daten-Rechorierung-Tool,
auf einem Prozess.
cu cu
Monero.
Da muss ich immer dran denken.
Hat nicht mal die Webseite von Cristiano Ronaldo
Monero gemeint.
Da war doch mal was.
Vor ein paar Jahren.
Ich erinnere mich dunkel.
die letzten Tage schon, ja.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Chat, Chat, muss mal kurz gucken.
Ist wieder hoch? Naja.
Naja, nee.
Chat,
meint ihr, meint ihr, jetzt ist der passende
Moment, reinzugehen?
Be connected!
Das ist keine Macht, das ist keine Gedanke.
Moment, ApoRed hat einen Coin?
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, ob das T-Bait ist.
Also das ist einer der ersten, denen ich das zutrauen würde, dass er einen Coin hat.
Das war doch ein gutes Fireship-Video.
Und das ganz ohne AI.
Nur für den Fall der Fälle, dass ihr euch nicht mehr dran erinnern könnt.
Ich muss mal kurz danach suchen hier.
Cristiano Ronaldo Mining Website.
Ja.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, Monero hat er gemeint.
Also,
eher nicht wirklich ja seine admins ich glaube nicht dass der davon irgendwas wusste
Ich habe im Video auch nicht alles verstanden von den Tools.
Ich kenne die auch nicht alle.
Kali Linux ist nicht mal angesagt, oder was?
Jetzt ist was Black Arch.
Penetration Testing.
Das sieht ja...
Also das Hintergrundbild ist ja schon mal genau richtig, ja?
Hörst du auf der Arbeit eigentlich auch die gleiche Musik wie hier im Stream?
Manchmal schon, ja.
Der Hintergrund sieht ja schon wirklich äußerst Hackerman-mäßig aus.
Black Arch, Full ISO.
Wie groß ist die Full-ISO?
Ah, Fluxbox.
Und i3 für die richtigen Hackermans unter uns.
Download.
ISO.
22 Gig gibt es natürlich nur über Torrent.
Wo wir wieder dabei sind, für was verwendet man Torrent?
Natürlich nur, um Linux-Distributionen runterzuladen.
Vor allem, warum ist es von 2023?
gibt es da nicht was neueres gibt keine news news sind outdated
15 jahre zuvor oder was benutzen die anderen peret os das kenne ich gar nicht dass operating
system vor hack der ultimate für cyber security operations hat patrick dankeschön für den sub
Exzellente Subscriptions hier.
Live, Virtual,
IoT, Security, Home.
Okay, das ist nicht so groß dann.
Also Kali ist gar nicht mal angesagt, oder was?
Das wird ja leider nicht mehr
geupdatet, Leute.
Sonst, das gibt's noch auf
SourceForge.
Das ist richtig
oldschool. Das ist KDE 4.2.
Leider keine Updates mehr.
Gibt es das eigentlich noch?
Das hatten wir doch mal installiert.
Ne, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das war das nicht.
Wie hieß das, was ich mal aus Spaß
auf Ubuntu installiert hatte?
muss da fahre für den sub übrigens leute wenn euch das stream gefällt und demnächst auch dabei
sein wollt wenn wir hier war cash us auf reisen hardware installieren oder das neue nass aus
probieren dann könnt ihr an der stelle jetzt auch einfach mal voll und meo bunto irgendwie sowas ja
Da gab es doch sowas wie hieß das denn?
Moe Ubuntu! Genau das hier!
Bester Ubuntu-Skin, Alter!
Das greift die Augen schon an.
Wie, für 22 LTS?
Gibt's da nicht was Neueres zu?
24 LTS gab es.
Wirklich, gab es 24 LTS?
Ich sehe hier kein 24 LTS.
Ich sehe nur 22 LTS.
Wo stand da 24 LTS?
Im Titel?
Achso.
Okay.
Das wird noch updated, ja?
Also.
wer sein ubuntu wie fixieren will
ubuntu
was soll schon schief gehen ja ich habe mich auch nur getraut dass man in der isolierten
vm zu installieren weil ich der sache nicht getraut habe
peper money best beste möglichkeit money zu bern twitch subscriptions
dürfen wir dieses im ort haben
komodo dürfen wir haben moment
Update
Äh
Ich bin
Ich bin zu dumm
Bei der Twitch-TV zu bedienen.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie die Seite funktioniert.
Channel?
Save?
Ist es jetzt da?
Ah!
Komodo.
Ist es jetzt da? Probiert mal Komodo Champ aus.
Nee, geht nicht.
Die Webseite ist...
Ich hab schon neu geladen.
Vielleicht macht man FFZ-komisches Ding.
Add-ons?
Geht nicht
Also ich hab das ausgewählt auf der Seite
Guck, wenn ich hier
Wenn ich hier
Das anzeigen lasse, da ist sogar mein Channel drin
Aber es geht irgendwie nicht
Braucht das einfach ein bisschen
Mit Seven TV siehst du es
AFFZ nicht?
Und dann?
Wo siehst du denn deine Ansichten?
Na gut.
Dann ist ja gut.
Von mir geht der Komodo
und jampt mich.
Naja, gut.
Wie dem auch sei.
Was gibt's heute zu essen?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Lass mich mal überlegen.
Was gibt's heute zu essen?
Das wird in der Tat
schwierig, was es zu essen gibt, weil
ich war Donnerstag, Freitag
auf diesem Teambuilding-Event
und hab gestern noch
Reste gefuttert.
Das heißt, ich hab eigentlich gar nichts mehr für heute.
Das heißt, ich muss mir irgendwas...
Wollte gerade sagen, ich muss mir irgendwas...
Wo habe ich das passende Emote dafür?
Wo ist mein Pipo-Fett-Emote?
Ich sehe mein Pipo-Fett-Emote.
Ah, hier.
Ich muss mir was Fettes bei Lieferando bestellen.
Nee, ich will mir heute nichts kochen.
Indisch habe ich lange nicht mehr gegessen.
Da hätte ich sogar mal Bock drauf.
Mal gucken.
Du kannst bei Lieferando auch einen Salat bestellen.
Ja, es gibt viele Sachen, die man machen kann.
Und wenn man die dann macht, ist es wieder was anderes.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Ach ja.
das habe ich auch mitgekriegt.
Curl hat jetzt ihr Bug-Bounty-Programm
eingestellt, weil zu viel AI-Slob
am Start war.
Kann ich aber irgendwie auch verstehen.
Da hätte ich
an den ihrer Stelle auch keinen Bock mehr drauf gehabt.
Die kriegen schon, ja, jetzt reicht
sie aber anscheinend. Das kann ich aber auch
verstehen. Das können wir mal tatsächlich kurz gucken.
Ich meine, da sind teilweise echt haarschräubende Reports drin gewesen.
Da muss ich das mal vorstellen, die haben nicht nur diesen Security-Ticket da aufgemacht,
sondern die haben sogar teilweise die Antworten in den Kommentaren auf dieses Ticket AI generiert.
Also die haben nicht nur geschrieben, hey, ich hab hier einen Bug gefunden und haben dann irgendeinen AI-Slob reingepastet, nein, die haben auch, wenn dann die Curl-Leute gesagt haben, hier und hier und wie kann man das reproducen, da hatten die eine AI-Antwort drin.
und lib curl, which are fantastic pieces of software that allow the entire...
Vor allem, vor allem ist curl schon richtig alt.
Das gibt es ja irgendwie auch schon seit, was weiß ich, 30 Jahren oder so.
...to make web requests programmatically is kind of the end state here, right?
So if you're not aware, for a long time, right, Daniel and friends have fought against the era of AI.
They have fought...
Da hat er einen Vortrag drüber gehalten.
49 Minuten.
...
Das mache ich mir mal auf.
Das können wir tatsächlich nicht unbedingt heute,
aber das können wir tatsächlich mal gucken.
Das ist der Curl
Maintainer,
der sich über AI
Slop
Reports aufregt.
Die haben richtig dumme Zeugs.
Ich hab mir da ein paar
Reports durchgelesen. Es ist so dumm.
Gerade wenn die mit AI dann auch noch auf die Sachen
geantwortet haben. Also das ist richtig
dämlich.
Und das sind richtig.
Okay, das Video müssen wir jetzt nicht gucken.
da ist nicht wirklich...
Ah, hier.
Ja, genau, hier zeigt er ein paar Sachen.
After free in
OpenSSL Keylog Callback
by SSL Get External Data
in Libcurl. A few things here.
First of all, this is a report
that talks about a vulnerability in...
Ich hab dort
einen Report gelesen,
wo
auch AI-Slob-mäßig
bei Curl Security reported
wurde. Und in dem
Proof of Concept
für diesen Security
wie heißt
denn das eigentlich korrekt?
Report für Sicherheitslücken, ja.
In dem Proof of Concept
wurde nicht mal Libcurl verwendet.
Die haben bei Libcurl, das
die AI hat gedacht, hier, guck mal da, ganz toll,
Libcurl und dann
wurde nicht mal Libcurl verwendet.
Open SSL,
which is a big deal if real however comma this is a vulnerability report platform for lib curl so
not sure what we're doing here and so he talks about the fact that there's a use after free if
it uses function which can crash your information leak it can be triggered manually blah blah blah
okay fine so let me see your code where's your where's your little fuzzer harness he has your
function called my key log callback which don't worry about what it does it's just it's a callback
that takes an ssl context and a pointer to a line okay and you say void pointer equals get the data
von der ssl kontext und dann in der funktion der main day create a new ssl kontext ist
es werden wir tls client wie initialize kontext wo wir kaltes so wie du so ein
stuff wie denn frieden so kontext und dann wie jesus kontext und das ist
vor allem auf der kleinen seite
MQTT Test Server in the curl project contains a buffer overflow vulnerability to improper validation of password length fields in MQTT.
Or this one, this one's pretty good.
Buffer overflow risk in curl, INET, N2P and INET N2P4, which are used to convert number to pointer.
Basically, it's an IP address conversion function that converts from the binary format to a human readable format.
Obviously, this could be vulnerable to something, right?
Because it has to do with converting a number to a string.
That being said, the string is generally always fixed length.
ist immer mehr denn 3 x 4 plus 3, right?
Like, digits, like, it's very hard to get this wrong.
But okay, let's give this guy a break and see what can happen.
Okay, so he says, hmm...
Wisst ihr, bei solchen Sachen ist AI halt richtig gut.
AI kann Mengen an Text generieren,
die auf den ersten Blick irgendwie so passen.
Wenn auch bei vielen AI-Sachen, wenn du da anfängst zu lesen
und denkst dir so, hä, jetzt komm mal zum Punkt,
hä, was willst du denn eigentlich?
boah, ey, das ist, aber die können
massen an Text generieren, das erstmal
ganz passabel aussieht.
Aber sobald du es anfängst, im Detail
anzugucken, gestern, ohne Scheiß,
gestern hat mir ChatGPT
so ziemlich die schlimmste Bash-Funktion
ausgespuckt, die ich bisher je
von ChatGPT
gesehen hab, ey. Guck mal.
Das hat mir ChatGPT gestern
vorgeschlagen. Ernsthaft.
Das hier.
Erkennt jemand das Problem daran,
Chat?
Was, was, wenn ihr das seht,
was fallen euch so für Probleme ein?
Was könnte da so das Fall,
dass das Ding Workdeer heißt?
Äh,
Also, wenn man diese Funktion aufruft,
wenn man diese Funktion aufruft,
ohne Parameter,
wird einfach das komplette
Dienungssystem gelöscht, wenn man das gut ausführt.
Weil, wenn man
das ohne Parameter aufruft, ist das hier leer,
ja, das hier leer,
und er macht
rm-rf-sternchen.
Easy, einfach keine Fehler machen, ne?
Sag ich ja auch immer. Einfach immer korrekt
aufrufen.
Gibt's da nicht ne Sicherung bei M-RF?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die greift
bei Slash, Slash, Stern.
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Bei Slash, ja,
bei Slash, Stern weiß ich nicht, ob das
Preserve, no,
Preserve,
irgendwie, Root, irgendwas,
No Preserve Root greift.
So.
Oder wenn einer beispielsweise sagt, hat einer auf Twitter geantwortet, work dir tilde für Home Directory. Bam, Home Directory vielleicht weg, weil hier da. Also das ist ganz weird. Ich habe ChatGPT danach auch geschrieben, Alter, was schreibst du für einen Scheiß? Und ChatGPT hat geschrieben, ja, diese Funktion ist äußerst gefährlich, bla bla bla.
Ja, warum schlägst du sie dann vor?
Ja, weil das oftmals in Bash-Skripten gemacht wird.
Aber du hast natürlich recht, das ist eine unsichere Funktion.
Alter.
Aber was soll der Sinn der Funktion sein?
Das musst du ChatGPT fragen, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe ChatGPT gestern dieses Skript hier mal reingeschmissen.
Ja, das hier.
Dieses Skript habe ich ChatGPT gestern mal reingeschmissen.
Ich habe gesagt, ey ChatGPT, hast du irgendwelche Verbesserungsvorschläge?
da kannst du einiges verbessern.
Bei JetGPT hast du irgendwelche Verbesserungsvorschläge.
Und ich mache halt ganz oft hier
mkdir,
einen Ordner hoch,
löschen alles da drinnen
und am Ende cde ich wieder rein.
Was bei mir kein Problem ist,
weil ich jetzt alles relativ dazu mache,
nie ein Slash rauskommen kann
und ich nach jedem Aufruf das wieder
in das Verzeichnis hier
vom Skript resette.
Schönste Variante ist es vielleicht auch nicht,
Und da hat ChatGPT gedacht, ey, da können wir doch eine Funktion draus machen,
wo man diese Parameter übergibt und das Gleiche da drin passiert.
Nur, dass die Funktion halt sehr gefährlich ist.
Das war eine der Antworten auf ChatGPT drauf,
wie man dieses Skript verbessern könnte.
Diese Funktion hier benutzen.
Ähm.
Alles nicht so schlau.
Das Video müssen wir jetzt nicht gucken.
Aber wir gucken uns dann im nächsten Stream mal hier an.
Wo hab ich's denn?
Den Vortrag von dem, hier.
Den Vortrag von dem Curl-Main-Trainer.
Nicht jetzt, das sind 49 Minuten,
sind wir jetzt ein bisschen lang.
Ich krieg nämlich langsam echt
brutal Hunger.
Da gab es doch, wir haben doch letztens das Video gesehen.
Heute Nachmittag installieren wir auf einer Hardwarekiste CacheOS.
Bin ich mal gespannt, wie das funzt.
Da können wir auch mal eine neue KVM gleich mal ausprobieren.
Nur fürs Installieren.
Später schließe ich da einen Monitor dran an und eine Capture Card.
Aber nur fürs Installieren können wir das mal auch ausprobieren.
Bei CacheOS, bei Bedside oder wie das hieß, gab es einen Maintainer Clash.
Vielleicht aber bei CacheOS auch.
Was für eine KVM? Hier, ich habe mir eine Pro KVM. Pro, ja, weißt du schon?
Im Namen, wenn im Namen Pro ist, dann kann nichts schief gehen.
Dieses Ding hier.
Ne, falsch.
Dieses Ding hier habe ich mir bestellt.
By the way, das sieht viel größer aus auf dem Bild, als es ist.
also das ist eigentlich
das ist halb so lang wie meine Hand
das ist gar nicht so groß
wie es hier aussieht
das Teil habe ich mir bestellt, das wollte ich mal ausprobieren
mein Chat-KVM
habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert
wäre die Alternative dazu gewesen
das probieren wir dann gleich mal aus
mal schauen,
ob das taugt.
Was ich bei dem ganz cool finde,
der hat ja auch so ein HDMI-Paththrough,
ähnlich wie eine Capture Card.
Da kann man dann quasi
noch eine Capture Card dahinter
schalten oder so.
Das probieren wir dann mal aus.
Und also, Ziel ist es, ich will CacheOS installieren
und darauf dann Keyboard Sharing.
Keyboard-Mouse-Sharing mit meinem
Main-Rechner.
Und wie war das
mit dem Monitor machen, muss ich mal gucken, weil
den zweiten Monitor, den ich hier
habe, den, ähm,
der hat kein HDMI, der hat tatsächlich
nur Displayport.
Und
das muss ich dann,
ich hab keinen Adapter, HDMI,
HDMI, Displayport da,
das heißt, ich muss dann die Capture
Card per HDMI anschließen, den Monitor
per Displayport und dann irgendwie Display mirroren,
dass ihr was seht.
Aber installieren und so,
das machen wir erstmal über die KVM und dann gucken wir uns das an.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie gut das
Funst, also, ähm, ich habe ja die
Hoffnung, CacheOS
out of the box, alles Funst,
ich, BTFS kommt drauf, auf die
Platte mit, äh, Snapshot Support.
Dann gucken wir uns das mal
an.
Eine was?
Eine C-Speed?
Was?
C?
C-Speed Nano KVM.
Das Mikro KVM.
Das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ah, nee, Nano.
Du meinst Nano KVM, ne?
Bilder.
Okay, das sieht heftig...
Das sieht nachher...
Oh, das sieht nachher eine heftige Bastellösung aus, Alter.
Selbst gedrucktes, 3D gedrucktes...
Das sieht schon gebastelt aus, ey.
Wobei das intern bestimmt auch gebastelt ist.
Mich würde mal interessieren, was da drin ist.
Ob da, vielleicht ist ja dann Raspberry Pi Zero oder irgendwie sowas drin.
Weil es geht ja auch über WLAN.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Vielleicht, wisst ihr was richtig mega nice wäre?
Wenn das Ding hier ein vollwertiger Linux-Rechner wäre,
da könnte man die KVM im Endeffekt ans Netzwerk anstöpseln
und da noch irgendwas drauf laufen lassen
und hätte quasi einen weiteren Linux-Rechner.
Ich meine eigentlich total sinnlos, weil die KVM
will es ja dann abstöpseln und woanders dran machen.
Die Nano-KVM ist sehr verrufen wegen
Chinaspionage. Das hier ist bestimmt
auch China-Chinesen-Zeug, oder?
Das sieht schon so eine AliExpress aus.
Okay, lass mal kurz gucken.
Hongkong, ja klar.
Ist bestimmt auch
ein Mikrofon drin.
Und wird Netzwerk mit gesnifft gleich und sonst was.
Doom. Doom läuft da bestimmt drauf.
Wenn da Nihilus draufläuft, läuft da bestimmt auch Doom drauf.
Was für ein Ding?
Open.
Hairface.
Die kompakte KV... Oh, was ist denn das? Das ist ja mega nice.
Wie darf ich mir das vorstellen?
Jetzt bestellen.
Das muss ich mir mal angucken.
Achso, ich habe ja keinen Sound in meiner VM, okay
Oh man, das Copy-Paste ist wieder kaputt
Oh MWR, fuck mich doch nicht so ab
Ah
Vor allem ist es heute schlecht geworden
Copy-Paste ist wieder kaputt, man
Was ist das denn?
Okay
Sleep starten.
Wie schlecht kann man eigentlich eine Software machen?
Die gingen ja. Die haben sie jetzt kaputt gemacht.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Die alten Feuerwehr-Versionen gingen ohne Probleme.
Es kam auch nichts an Features dabei,
was irgendwie...
Okay.
Open Interface.
Enable Studio-to-your-own-Laptop-SKVM-Konsolen-Zugriff.
Er braucht eine App.
Kann man da nicht mit dem Browser drauf?
Äh, warum?
Das andere sah aus wie ein USB-Stick.
Das ist doch wieder was ganz was anderes.
Das andere sah aus wie ein USB-Stick, das fand ich viel nicer.
Das andere fand ich...
Open-terface.
Das finde ich mega.
Das, das...
Ah, hier.
Pika vor allem kenne ich, ja.
Moment.
VGA, mit VGA-Stecker noch.
Okay, okay.
warum ist die video qualität so schlecht
das sieht ja oldschool aus
micro sd karten lange play kaffee abtun okay das heißt du steckst das hier in den display
Port und auf der anderen Seite, wie sah es von der anderen Seite nochmal aus?
Andere Seite Netzwerkkabel und USB.
What's in the box?
Okay, lassen wir mal kurz gucken. KVM, also das Ding hier.
Ach, man kriegt drei verschiedene auch gleich.
Mit VGA, Displayport und HDMI.
Achso, du hast recht, das ist gar kein Netzwerkkabel.
Äh, und wie kommt man dann da drauf?
Wie, wie, wie, wie kommt man dann da dran?
Das ist, das ist dann quasi nur eine Mini-Capture-Card, oder wie?
Man muss, man braucht einen Laptop oder mit der App.
Okay.
Host, MacBook, Target, Headless, Windows, PC.
Okay, man braucht sie sogar.
Plugin, Target, USB.
Okay, das ist quasi so eine...
Naja, das...
Find ich dann schon immer so geil.
Du musst ja quasi Laptop haben,
wenn du da einen Serverraum willst.
Oder an deiner Kiste.
Da kann ich auch einfach mein HDMI-Kabel verlängern und meine Elgato Capture Card anschließen.
Geht auch mit Android iOS.
Ja, aber du musst dich auch bei USB dann daran verbinden, oder?
Weil anscheinend hat es ja nur USB.
Die Musik, Alter.
Ja, du musst das
per USB mal...
Ja, dann ist es, finde ich, schon
nur noch halb so geil.
Wenn das keine
Netzwerkverbindung hat.
Hast du letztens
mal was mit deinem Home Assistant gemacht?
Nö, der läuft einfach und tut.
Nee, dann ist es schon mal nicht so geil
Ich weiß nicht, nee
Nee, nee, nee, dann finde ich es doch nicht so toll
Na gut
So, nachher, Leute, installieren wir Cache auf der Ryzen-Kiste hier
Ich gehe jetzt was essen
Dann bin ich nachher wieder am Start
Ich kann es euch nicht genau sagen, wann exakt
Ja, aber erstmal in Ruhe was futtern
ohne mich zu hetzen
wir sehen uns nachher
wer dabei sein will, kann jetzt ein Follow da lassen
würde mich freuen, bis denn, macht's gut
CU